Hello everybody!
Sorry, sorry that we were a little bit late today.
I sort of went into the Planet of the Apes rabbit hole.
I was reading up like... oh my god.
Oh, I died.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What happened?
What?
Okay.
Okay, Mike like fucking...
Okay, apparently did not like that.
Give me a sec.
I don't know what happened.
I just... it just crashed.
Okay, where is that?
That was... whoa.
That was awkward.
Maybe it's the quality.
Oh no, is this a fucking Bitcoin miner?
Is this a...
Oh no.
Is this a Bitcoin miner?
Alright, we're gonna... we're gonna... we're gonna see if it's a Bitcoin miner soon.
I put it... I put it on medium graphics to see if that'll fix it.
Don't worry.
I'll be back very soon.
Oh my god!
You know what sucks?
I worked so hard putting on my barista apron into coffee.
That's the worst part.
The fact that I spent... actually spent time putting on my uniform and then it just fucking crashes.
Oh, this is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
I have to put that shit back on.
Come on.
Okay.
Give me a sec guys.
Grab my coffee order too.
Alright, there we go.
Okay.
Alright, let's try this again.
Alright.
That's a little awkward.
Is this it?
Why is it... why am I not... why am I not up on the screen?
Hello?
Oh, there I am.
Okay, give me a second.
I'm gonna put this back on.
I need...
Give me a sec.
I need to put this back on everybody.
Alright, let's see.
And then it was like right here.
Alright.
I think that was it.
Alright, give me a sec.
I need to take off my... I need to take off my jacket.
I forgot.
I'm not supposed to wear a jacket when I'm at work.
Uh...
I can't wear my jacket when I'm at work.
My boss is gonna kill me.
I can't.
They're like... it's not appropriate attire apparently.
So I have to take it off.
Alright, there we go.
Okay.
There we go.
That was... I don't know what the fuck just happened there.
Holy shit.
I just crashed out of nowhere.
Alright.
Anyway, I'm back on my uniform again.
And I have my uniform again.
Uh... yeah.
Alright, there we go.
Alright!
Welcome!
Welcome back!
Don't worry.
The barista is back.
I'm ready to do my minimum wage job.
Oh... I gotta be grounded in reality.
I gotta know what it's like to have a minimum wage job again.
So I can appreciate you... I can appreciate people more.
Um...
I know!
Anyway, welcome.
Welcome guys.
Um... for those who don't know, I actually have two really big announcements.
Um... I have two really big announcements to make today.
But that will be at the end of the stream.
So you gotta watch me work my minimum wage job before...
You gotta wait until my shift is over before you can figure out what the announcements are.
You gotta...
You gotta wait until my shift is over.
I can't... guys, I can't announce when I'm working.
Guys... dragoons, I can't announce when I'm working, dragoons.
My boss isn't gonna like it!
Dude, he's gonna dock my tips!
He's gonna take my tips, guys!
You don't understand!
I work like four dollars and... wait, what's minimum...
I know they like... they increase minimum wage, but because of inflation...
I know they don't usually do that anymore because like, you know, society.
But like...
Not in Europe or Australia!
I know you guys get paid a lot better.
But like, in NA, they stopped really raising the minimum wage these days to account for inflation.
They sort of stopped doing that.
So like, I hope...
It's like eleven dollars?
Okay, it's eleven... okay, chat's dead.
Don't worry, I'll revive chat.
Chat, don't worry!
I have coffee, chat!
We're gonna feed you some coffee and then you're gonna be back to life!
Alright.
Pew!
And then...
Okay, there we go.
Sorry, we're...
Today's a sort of special day for this announcement.
Um... but yes!
Welcome!
Welcome to Barista Simulator!
Um... you know, usually at like 12.30 PM streams, I usually find some... try to find some interesting games for 12.30.
They're usually called like one-off days.
Unless I'm trying to complete a long series.
12.30 PM is... tends to be like one-off streams.
Anyway, I thought this was really interesting.
I was reading the reviews and then some of them was like, this is stressful.
Ten out of ten.
I'm like, you know what?
I need more stress in my life.
It's not like I cried like yesterday because I was so stressed out.
You know what?
I think I need more stress.
I think I need...
I think I...
I think I need more of that.
Oh my God.
Anyway.
Um... apparently they're saying like, yeah, these coffee orders tend to get like super realistic.
So like, good luck.
And I'm like, yeah, alright.
I've never worked.
I honestly... I've never worked.
Um... as...
Well, I cried because like I needed to let it out.
It's not good.
It's not good to like have it all kept up inside you.
Like when you're really stressed out.
So I had like a nice cry because I was like, I needed to let it out.
And I was like...
And then I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Because it's better... it's better than keeping it...
Oh my God.
My PC...
Why is my PC letting out so much hot air?
It's peris...
This is not well optimized.
This is not a well optimized game.
Holy shit.
I...
I just booted this game up.
What are you...
All that is a Bitcoin miner.
This is definitely mining some crypto right now for somebody in Europe.
Anyway.
I'm giving some people some PTSD right now.
Wearing my barista uniform.
And playing this game.
But you know what?
Let's...
Let's try.
I've never been a barista before.
I've never...
I've never done...
I've never been...
Worked as a barista before.
So like this will be interesting.
I worked as...
You know why I did similar?
I worked as an unpaid family member at a restaurant.
You know like...
You know it's like family owned restaurants.
And then you worked as an unpaid labor.
Because you're family.
That's what I did.
So it's practically the same thing.
Instead...
Instead I just didn't get paid.
I didn't get paid.
I got some free bubble tea.
At least.
My game crashed.
I think it's barista simulator.
I think...
Holy shit.
Okay let me like...
Let me put it as like the lowest graphics possible.
I think we gotta put this as the...
The lowest...
Lowest graphics possible for this game.
I don't think this game is meant to be played at all.
Alright.
Woah.
That changed a lot.
Oh my god.
We don't need shadows guys.
Okay maybe not like very low.
Maybe just regular low.
Alright.
Maybe regular low should be okay.
Um...
I can't believe it.
This PC has a 4080 I think.
Or 90.
Anyway.
Guys, anyway.
If you guys wanna know what the announcements are.
They're pretty big announcements.
One will be about what the special stream is tomorrow.
And the other one is something else.
So um...
You guys wanna know what it is?
You gotta wait until my shift is over guys.
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You reckon I can get this maid to sing me a happy birthday?
Also what was that about plan dapes you were gonna say?
Thank you for the super chat Gladstone.
Thank you.
Of course.
Gladstone.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Glatzone.
Yeah!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, the reason why I was late was because I was in the rabbit hole regarding Planet of the Apes lore.
So like...
I was reading... I was reading up about Planet of the Apes because recently I was watching... I watched the Kingdom of the Apes and like I'm... okay.
This is like spoiler.
This is like a spoiler.
But like I was like, okay.
Okay.
There was this particular scene where they surrounded the evil main character.
It was... this is the ending and it was like this particular scene where they surrounded this evil main character and then like...
and then like... okay.
And then like the thing is they could just push him.
Because they were at the cliff.
They could have just pushed him.
There was like... like 20 of them.
So like 20 plus.
So I couldn't understand like why they just like... were like, oh no this one guy.
It's just one guy!
Push him!
And I couldn't understand!
Like they had to go instead they like called out for the birds to like use the birds to push him.
So like I was just like what... why?
There's at least 30 of you!
What happened to apes together strong?
It's not birds together strong.
It's apes together strong.
So I was like incredibly confused about that.
Anyway, I started looking up.
Sorry that wasn't like... that has nothing to do regardless.
Regarding the rabbit hole of the kingdom of the hearts.
Sorry not kingdom of the hearts.
Sorry I'm not talking about kingdom.
Kingdom of the apes.
It has nothing to do regarding why I was in the rabbit hole.
But I just had to talk about the ending of that movie.
Because that made zero sense for me.
I was just like push him!
It's one guy!
It doesn't matter!
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway sorry.
Anyway.
I was like really curious about the lore of like...
Uh...
The lore about like...
Planet of the apes and everything regarding the newest series.
So I was like reading up like each character.
And like getting to know about like...
Like the society of the plat...
Also like I don't know if you guys remember but like...
The... not the original but the reboot of the planet of the apes was like...
Was it...
14 years ago?
Oh my god.
Why is this game crashing?
Oh my god!
Okay maybe it's because I'm not playing the game.
So then the game boots me up because I'm not playing the game.
But yeah.
The planet of the apes...
The reboot of the movie released like...
Oh my god it released in 2011.
It was like 2011.
Did you guys know that Andy Serkis is like...
Almost 70 now?
He's like...
Okay how old is Andy Serkis?
Um...
He's like...
Oh he's 60 years old now.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
He's 60 years old!
Yeah!
Holy shit!
He's 60 years old!
That's the guy that does all the...
Atomos like...
Atomos like 3D shit.
Like you know like Gollum and everything.
And he always does like the tracking.
The 3D tracking for like...
Like shit that moves weird.
Like...
Yeah...
I was like...
Um...
But...
Yeah.
I was like...
So surprised.
Oh my god.
Planet of the apes is like...
2011.
There's...
Oh my god.
Speaking of 2011.
Somebody in my...
Okay.
During like...
Okay so like...
Um...
During Anime Expo...
Uh...
Yusong sang a song...
That I...
I sang an anime song and it was apparently a Boomer anime song.
But like I didn't like that's what like that's what they said.
They were like I'm gonna sing a Boomer anime song and I didn't really know what it's from.
Because like I have very little knowledge of anime in general.
So then I was like haha Boomer you're old and then like and then so because I didn't really know what the song was in general.
I was just like hee hee it's a Boomer song and I still don't I don't remember what song it was again.
I actually don't remember and then...
No, they sang a solo song for by themselves for like anime Expo for the karaoke.
And then somebody like tweeted at us and was like that's not old.
The show came out in 2010.
And then I didn't call that I almost called them out in public because I don't think they realize how long ago 2010 was.
I didn't call them out.
Like I didn't name them out specifically.
I almost did because it was on like Twitter and I almost was almost replied back 2010 was 14 years ago.
14 years is long ago.
14 years.
That's like the age where you can create a Twitch account.
That's like where you can finally watch Twitch streamers.
14 years ago is not guys.
I don't know how 14 years ago is a very long time guys.
That's what I'm like you were born and then you're off to middle school discovering girls or boys for the first time.
And you know, hey, let's see.
Let's see.
Okay, let's actually try and play this game.
I hope I don't actually crash when I'm playing playing the game.
Maybe it's the loading screen.
Maybe the start screen is like, okay.
What should I coffee shop name be started from scratch play realistic barista experience while managing designing your own coffee shop by all the equipment.
Oh my God.
This is basically like supermarket simulator before.
For like a coffee shop.
All right.
What is like a good?
What's a good coffee shop name?
It has to be like super super hipsters because hip are hipsters.
So thing I still think where is that like old now for like Gen Z Alpha do do the Gen Z's know what hipsters are shall shall shall anti-doki explain what a hipster is to the Gen Z Alpha.
Let's see.
Yeah, pretty sure it's charcoal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chad.
You want to feel old?
Halo is considered a retro game because it's 20 years old.
Anyway, so like a hipster is what we used to call like people who are like I used to like this before.
It was cool.
That's what a hipsters are and hipsters tend to usually go to.
I very very expensive expensive mediocre coffee, which is what our coffee shops going to be today.
Expensive coffee, please buy.
There you go.
That's a shop.
Oh wait.
No, wait.
I got a better name.
Okay guys, I'm going to dismantle the shop again.
I'm going to dismantle guys.
I've got figure out a better name.
I'm going to dismantle the shop.
All right.
Okay guys, I'm going to feel a little adventurous.
I'm just assuming that it's the main menu.
That's graphics are like super fucked up.
So I'm feeling a little bit adventurous and I'm going to put medium graphics.
It might be just see it could just be the main menu guys.
Expensive coffee, please.
Super chat.
Okay.
That's a new name.
Let's see.
I move your character fill pick up.
Oh pick up and fill are the same thing inventory.
All right, that's cool.
We do I live here?
Do I live in my own entered?
Okay.
I need to turn down the sensitivity.
The sensitivity is so fucking high sense.
All right, there you go.
All right.
Okay.
I don't live.
I live next.
Okay.
That's my house.
All right.
Okay.
This is fucked up.
All right guys.
I put all my life savings.
No kid is going to college because I dipped into the college fund up by this coffee shop.
Oh, but there's free Wi-Fi.
I can afford Wi-Fi and use useful features related to cleaning or character management.
In the game by pressing the spacebar.
Okay, trash pin.
Oh broom.
All right, sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet guys.
Sweet sweet sweet.
Okay, increase the cleanest level of the shop.
All right guys.
I dipped into the Dragoon College fun guys.
This is very important.
This is my lifelong dream.
All right, you dragos are not going to college because this you guys don't want me to follow my dreams.
dragos.
I'm not going to college.
All right.
Oh wait, why the fuck is there cigarette here?
Okay, sweep sweep sweep.
Grab the trash to clean it.
Oh shit.
How do I get this broom away?
All right.
Wait grab the trash.
How did I open my trash can again?
Oh my God.
How did I forget?
Oh, there you go trash.
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
Your future that's don't worry.
We're going to make a better future guys.
We're going to make a better future.
For all of us.
You look we're going to be it so rich.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's no coffee.
I look at use the chat.
Wait, they're not pick up all the trash.
Okay.
There you go guys guys.
You don't understand.
I'm going to be able to afford all your college tuitions after this.
We're going to take you to an Ivy League school with the amount of money.
I'm going to make turn on the fuse box.
Okay use box.
All right, and then use the main computer for it.
Um, uh, keep on thinking of the super chat thing.
Thank you.
I got my bachelor years ago dip away.
That's why you're not getting a master's degree.
Uh, use the main computer for cafe management order a pack of coffee beans and order a mini size coffee.
Okay, I can do that.
All right, you're going to get wait.
Can I not go a lower quality?
I said buy good quality coffee.
Uh, all right.
We gotta get mini coffee cup.
All right.
We only have what is it called a grande?
Wait, what's the small size?
There you go.
Hon George.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's my college money.
Now.
I'm going to work at a mini wage job.
They give the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh order an expresso machine.
All right.
Got a dip into Hon George's college fund.
Express.
So machine.
Nice.
All right.
We got the expression machine.
I should just get the cheapest shit and then overpriced it.
But you guys can't tell you guys don't know what good if you guys knew what good coffee is.
You would make your own coffee.
You would do homemade coffee.
You would not go to a coffee shop like actual coffee snobs would make their own coffee.
Holy shit.
My packages.
Is this Amazon?
Sure.
If you actually know what good coffee tastes like you would not be going and wasting that money at a coffee shop.
You think I don't know?
Let's see install the machine on the table rotate.
All right.
Let's see.
You're going to go here.
There you go.
Oh my expression machines are industrial fully automated machines.
It has many functions.
But the most basic is.
Extracting espresso from ground coffee.
Guys.
I need to open the window.
I'm already.
I'm already overwhelmed.
Okay.
More advanced have automatic milk printers and grinders to speed up your work.
Come with it.
It filled.
What the fuck is?
Wait.
What does this mean?
Oh my God.
Did I hope this makes sense to people?
Okay.
I think I think we can.
I think we can do this.
I think.
I think I think we can do this.
Is.
All right.
Let's grab.
Where's my box?
This is not my supplies.
Am I missing some more supplies?
What are we missing?
Oh, here you go.
I got stack this.
Oh, I can't while press the spacebar to write the customers name.
Oh my God.
I can write people's names.
Wait.
That's so like.
Wow.
That's actually it.
That's so interactive.
Okay.
How do I put this away?
There we go.
Place supplies on the shelves.
Place my one coffee being that I can only afford.
Any chance we get deep lore video about Transformers, you know, vows and spice all.
No, I'm dead.
Reg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's so cute.
I like that.
You can actually do stuff.
Open your shop.
Oh my God.
What's the company?
My shop were open funded by my Dragoons college tuition.
All right.
Hello.
What would you like?
Okay, take.
All right.
And then right while holding press the spacebar.
What's your name?
Lady?
Hello.
What's your name?
Liberty.
Oh my God.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna draw you a nice picture.
There you go.
It's like the Statue of Liberty.
Look at that.
All right.
Here you go.
Liberty.
I'm gonna make you your coffee.
I put that I grab this.
I know that's the cup.
I that's the cup.
Give me a sec Liberty.
I Liberty, please.
Wait a moment.
Okay, I grabbed this and then I I filling you can use to transfer.
Okay, and then I I put the coffee bag in I filled the coffee beans in the grinder.
I turn it on.
I I I pick it up.
I did not Is that not the what's the grinder?
Oh, okay.
I filled it in.
Okay.
Guys, I'm learning.
I pick it up.
I grind.
I grind grind grind.
Oh my God.
I'm figuring out.
Are you Liberty?
Look at me.
Yeah.
Liberty.
Are you enjoying this getting the first-hand experience?
None of my dragons are going to college, but I have a coffee shop now.
And then thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, ma'am.
Can I speak to you?
I am the manager.
Hey, hey, hey.
I'm the only person here.
And then we fill it up.
Oh my God.
This is so realistic.
And then we put this down and we press the button.
Oh, no, we place this and we put it in and then place the shot glass.
Why would you need shots for coffee?
It's not alcohol guys.
I've never made coffee before.
I just watch somebody do it because I don't care.
Because I'm not pretentious.
I just went
JK.
I drink canned coffee.
I don't even drink regular coffee.
I just drink canned coffee.
It's just so much easier.
Is this not on?
Okay.
Is it ready?
Is it?
Oh, it's doing it.
Oh my God.
It's do.
I'm so good at this.
I'm making coffee.
Liberty.
Are you seeing this Liberty?
You're not late for work.
I know you have nothing else in your life.
Liberty.
Don't lie to me.
You have nothing else to do with your life and you're paying $80 for a coffee.
From a coffee store that just opened today.
With only one order.
Okay, we pick it up and then we put it.
We fill this in.
Did I fill it correctly?
This is all you want.
Please.
Is that it?
That's just that's it.
Should I put other stuff in this coffee?
College is four years.
Exactly.
Coffee is forever.
Coffee is going to be a good investment.
Everybody needs coffee because everybody's too lazy.
To make their own.
Andy, they give the super chat.
Thank you.
And then coffee is an addiction.
I should put more.
She's happy.
She's happy guys.
Oh my God.
Okay.
After using you need get rid of the coffee.
Why do I need to get rid of the coffee?
Isn't it like cooking?
We're like like the wouldn't it be like cooking, you know, we're like the essence of the coffee can like enhance the flavor.
Like why would you need to clean the beans?
I don't understand.
Why would you need it?
In fact, like it?
What do you mean?
Toki?
I'm just saying like wouldn't it work if how do I empty the knockbox?
Is this the knockbox?
Am I holding the knockbox?
No, I'm not.
Okay.
I'm putting it back in.
Okay, the knockbox.
What the fuck is a knockbox?
What is that?
What is this?
What's a knockbox?
Guys, what what is this?
Uh, what's the knockbox?
I don't understand.
Empty it.
How do I empty it?
Empty the knockbox.
How do I?
How do I empty this?
Toss.
Oh.
Do I toss it in here?
But like I can just I should just be able to toss a little bit and then like keep some of it in to enhance the flavor.
Guys, you can tell I never made coffee before.
Guys, can you tell this is my first time?
I usually don't order coffee.
I usually order a...
Usually, I usually...
I order like...
London Fog or like I just drink canned coffee.
If I order like a coffee order, it's usually a latte.
Let's see.
Look at the coffee recipe.
There's a coffee.
I need to know the coffee recipe.
Oh my God.
What do you mean?
I need to know the coffee recipe.
Holy shit.
You know how London Fog is so easy to make?
You just get like Earl Grey and then you put like vanilla extract.
That's London Fog.
That's literally it.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Espresso is very intense and espresso based.
Okay, that's that's alright.
That seems doable.
The name means double Italian refers to a double shot for two espresso shot.
Okay.
I'm going to...
I...
What's the difference?
What?
What's...
What's the difference?
It's just more coffee beans, right?
Yeah, it's 90, 60.
Okay, I can do this.
Alright.
Oh, I can go home now.
One or...
We're one and done.
Family!
I'm home!
I made $10!
Family!
Look at that!
Dragons!
I made $10 today!
Are you guys proud of me?
$500?!
Oh my God!
Guys, I got a $490 tip from Liberty.
I told you she had nothing to do with her life.
I...
I fucking knew it.
I knew she had nothing to do with her life.
If she came to this coffee shop.
Hello?
What would you like, sir?
Edwin!
You want a mini triplo?
I got you, sir.
How do I...
Say yes.
Okay, mini triplo.
Okay.
What's your name?
Edwin.
Okay, Edwin.
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
I would like one red super for this.
Alright.
We're gonna charge him $100, guys.
Okay, and then we're gonna put this here.
And then...
Wait.
I don't...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I pick it up.
I grind it.
Put it all the way up.
Grind, grind, grind.
Alright.
And then I put it in...
How do I fill it up?
Okay, I've...
I've picked this up.
And then I...
Put it down.
And then I pick this up.
And I fill it up.
Is that...
Is that enough?
What was it?
Uh...
Triplo.
Is triplo like...
What was triplo again?
Triplo is...
Triplo.
It is 90 milliliters.
Oh my god.
What the fuck are you doing with your life?
Alright.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
And then I put it in.
Set the dosage as double shot.
Produce 60 milliliters instead of 30.
Oh, but I need like...
Three.
So that means I need like...
I need like...
I need to do like two shots plus one.
Okay.
And then...
Go.
Alright.
And I have to do another one.
Two plus one.
Guys, I'm doing it!
I'm running my own coffee shop!
Okay.
Hey, Edwin.
I know you also have nothing to do with your life.
You a trust fund kid, Edwin?
Cause why the fuck are you here?
Alright.
Guys, why does this take so long?
Does it usually take this long to make coffee?
Look at how excited he is for his coffee.
Yeah, he's so excited.
He's so exci- Oh, affiliate!
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
You can't say he really likes his coffee.
If he really likes his coffee, he would not be in this store.
He would not.
He would not be here buying my coffee.
Cause I bought the cheapest brand at Walmart.
I bought the cheapest coffee beans at Walmart.
Alright.
And then...
I'm gonna go to the next one.
Let me fill it up.
That's like 60.
This is just one caffeine?
Is that really all you want?
Is it...
Oh, I have to do it again?
Holy shit!
What?
Okay, and then I put it in the knock box.
And then I have to grind it up again.
And...
You have to make another one.
Oh my god.
This is just a service.
I know the people at my coffee shop...
I know people at Tim Hortons does not do this.
The staff members at Tim Hortons does not do as much as I'm doing right now.
No!
Edwin!
Did you not like my story?
I can't do this fast!
You want a triple!
Okay, she wants to...
Oh my gosh.
Lucky for you.
Um...
I...
I got...
I got a drink for you.
Ms. Gurtu.
I can't do this faster!
What do you mean?
I can't do this!
I need somebody else to help me!
He wants to grind the coffee beans for me!
You had... Edwin had nothing to do in his life!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe he would just leave!
Alright, there you go.
Here you go, here's your coffee.
Is it not what you want?
That's a mini triplo!
Oh, I have to ring the bell.
Yay!
At least somebody's out.
Holy shit!
That was $140!
Can I like hire staff?
Cafe, to hire a barista, I need a level 2 store.
Where do I get to level 2?
Oh, I'm almost there!
I need to hire a barista!
I don't want to be a barista anymore!
I don't want to be a barista!
You also want a triplo?!
Oh my god!
I should have been grinding coffee since the beginning!
You need fresh?
Is there not 60 in there?
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, I'm...
Fucking Oscar is not getting his coffee.
That's for sure.
Alright, I just want to be an owner.
I just want to be a coffee shop owner.
I don't want to be...
I don't want to do the hard work anymore.
Yes!
What is that?
Minimum wage is so difficult!
I don't want to be a streamer forever!
Poor, poor, poor.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
We should latte right?
I'm sorry!
This is not fair!
This is not an Asian coffee shop!
I don't know how to do any latte art!
Alright.
Don't worry guys.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking...
It's...
Oh, I grinded coffee!
I have a refill!
Don't worry, please Oscar!
Please!
Save for me, Oscar!
There's no decaf...
We don't serve decaf tension!
It's just coffee!
That's all we have!
Not even art in the cup!
Oh my god, I forgot to even...
Okay, I'm gonna use this.
I'm gonna pour this one in.
This is the only one I have.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
And then we're gonna put that.
And then we're gonna pick up this.
And we're gonna...
Oh, please!
And then we're gonna throw...
No!
It's full!
Oh!
Okay.
Escape.
Add inventories.
Pick up the item.
I have...
There's an electric one too?
Oh my god, I need that.
Okay, and then...
And then we put...
Is this the bad coffee?
I think it is.
And then Oscar, please.
Please stay with me.
We're almost done with your order, Oscar.
Please!
Why does everybody want a triplo?
I don't understand!
Boom.
Oscar, please!
I'm making the triplo as fast as I can!
Oscar!
There's no...
We don't sell hot chocolate gingerbread!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god, I should start grinding more coffee!
Okay, fill, fill, fill, fill, fill, fill that coffee up.
And then...
Oh, wait, wait.
Is it done?
Is this done?
I can't tell.
No, there's still 60?
I put them!
One!
Oh, okay.
Oscar, please.
We're almost done.
Oscar, please stay with us a little longer, Oscar!
Okay, Oscar.
Okay.
All right.
Yay!
Oh, okay.
What do I have to do?
Did I finish grinding it?
No, no, I didn't.
All right.
Grind, grind, grind.
Pick this up.
Throw it away.
No, lady, please!
I want to upgrade my store!
They don't need lids!
They're gonna drink it up!
Okay.
All right.
Oh, okay.
That's...
Is that one?
Oh, my God.
I don't remember the recipe.
I have two recipes and I don't even remember the recipes already.
Oh, it's just a double shot!
All right.
And then we're gonna pick that up.
Boom!
There we go.
All right.
Don't worry.
I got you.
All right.
What's your name?
What's your name, ma'am?
I'm gonna call...
What's your name?
Madeline?
Nice.
That's also a red...
I don't know.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
All right.
Don't worry, Madeline.
I got you.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
I...
Fuck it.
I need to buy.
I have enough money, right?
Actually, no.
I should save up for a barista.
I should...
I'm gonna save up for a barista so I don't have to do this anymore.
Can I get a...
Never mind.
Thank you for the supertube.
I'm gonna go buy a barista.
I'm gonna buy a barista.
Thank you.
Okay.
We gotta fill this up.
No, we have enough coffee beans still.
I mean, I guess we...
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Okay.
And then, we fill that up.
Guys, I know we're missing something.
I remember why this feels off right now.
But first off, we gotta give this to her.
Yeah!
What the fuck?
She took the entire tray with her.
Oh, a customer wrote a review.
Your shop will only operate during the fall of... wait, my shop's closed.
Wait, my shop's... how did you get in here?
Wait, my shop... what?
How did she get in here?
My shop was closed.
Guys, I'm sorry ma'am.
It's illegal for you to be here.
Like, it's illegal.
Why are you...
Why are you here?
Okay, I guess I have to take her order.
Alright.
Is it double?
What was your order?
That's a 60, right?
How did I already forgot?
That is a 60.
Okay.
Boom.
Alright.
Okay, we got...
Oh!
These coffees on a whole...
other level...
fake review.
Oh!
Wait, that's not what I meant.
You should...
Alright, nice.
Oh, I should buy the coffee beans.
Uhh... we need...
Uhh...
Coffee beans, standard...
I want the cheapest kind.
Is there a way to buy cheaper coffee?
We have...
They're all the same types of coffee though.
They're all so expensive.
Uhh... we'll just get...
We'll just get the regular $25.
We'll just get that.
Alright, that should be... Oh, we should fill this up again.
Fill it up.
You'll never notice.
Uhh...
This is just... I can't watch her be stressed.
This is just making me stressed.
I'm just giving PTSD to people.
There's so much information online.
Doctor thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, here you go.
Madeline.
Wait!
Oh, wait, did I not...
Where did I... wait, where did my cup go?
Did I just pour into another shot glass?
Did I never make you a cup?
I thought I wrote you a... Oh, what was your name?
Oh, Savannah!
I forgot to give you a name!
There you go.
You get a real name.
Alright.
Uhh...
I poured it into another shot glass.
A great streamer will watch again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know.
Oh my gosh, she's so happy.
Okay, I'm almost there.
I'm almost at...
Okay, that should be closed now.
Alright, now I have the shop to myself.
Okay, let me see.
What do I need to do to my shop?
I have an 87% excellence.
These coffees are a whole new level.
This place rocks.
Best coffee in town.
Look at that.
Everybody loves my coffee, chat.
Everybody loves it.
I should sell cookies.
I should.
Do I have a license to sell, like, cookies?
Well, we'll find out soon.
Alright, let's see.
What else can I make?
The Espresso Machine A100.
It can make espresso faster.
Okay, I don't need that.
If I have a barista, I'll be fine.
Um...
Those are...
They're not bots!
They're just as real as you guys.
They're just...
Just as real!
Why are they all locked?
Please!
I spent my Dragoons tuition funds to open my dream store!
My dream coffee shop!
Okay, staff hire.
We're almost there.
Wait, we're level two.
Cafe upgrade.
I can have bodyguards?
Am I gonna get robbed?
Am I...
Like, what?
Am I gonna get robbed?
I'm gonna get robbed?
Alright.
How do I...
First, you unlock your cafe to level two.
What does...
What guarantees a level two?
Why would I need parking space?
Why would I need security?
Why...
I'm so confused.
Oh my god!
A hundred dollars a day?
What the fuck?
What the...
I don't even get paid a hundred dollars a day.
$100 a day.
Wait...
Okay.
Alright, Liam.
You gotta pay your college to it.
What the fu- Oh, Liam's fell on hard times.
Oh my god.
Poor Liam.
Okay, let me clean this.
And clean this.
And pick up my garbage bag.
And...
Wait, my cafe's starting to get dirty.
Where's the... where's the trash?
Liam, where's the trash?
Where is...
Where...
Where do I put the trash?
Can I just put the trash here?
I'm just gonna put it here.
This doesn't count, right?
This counts as my cafe?
There's no way that counts.
It's not even on my property anymore.
Who's gonna be at the back- Oh, it's over here.
Who's gonna be at the back side of my property?
Like, I don't...
Wait, it didn't even matter!
I would've literally just thrown... What the f- What happened?!
What happened to my store?!
Liam, did you do this?!
Okay.
Um... alright, let's see.
We gotta... Oh my god, Liam.
I gotta sweep.
We gotta sweep.
Liam, I know like, the financial crisis was like... I know like, people were having a hard time, Liam.
And I know that like, your work doing this for your family.
Liam, please.
I need you.
Please.
You should have more than one job.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Sweep, please.
Okay, what time?
At 8 AM.
Okay, Liam, do you know how to... Do you know how to make coffee, Liam?
Do you know how to make coffee?
He gets paid $100 a day.
You cannot say... You cannot say that Liam does not know... Does not get paid enough.
Liam gets paid plenty of money.
$100 a day.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna put this supply here.
My stocks are...
That doesn't even include tips!
I'm earning better than like 80% of like American restaurant owners because 80% of them operate on tips alone and pay like fairly minimum wage.
That doesn't even include the tips!
Who tips baristas?
I tip baristas!
Cause I'm a decent person!
I tip 15% percent!
I'm an actual decent person!
Okay...
Um... Alright, we got...
I think I know why I'm like really stressed out.
I need some coffee... I need some coffee music.
I need coffee shop music!
Okay...
Coffee shop copyright free music!
Now I know why I'm like extra stressed out.
There we go!
Can you guys hear this?
You guys hear it?
Alright...
Alright, how about coffee and ambient?
I need like ambient noise so it feels like... I feel like I'm actually in a coffee shop.
I need it!
Oh my god!
Alright...
There we go guys.
Give me a sec.
Can you hear this?
Alright...
Oh my god, the longer he's... I need to go to bed.
I need...
I need to be more immersed guys.
Alright, same.
Okay, I'll up it up a little bit too.
Um...
I'll up it up a little bit.
There we go.
There we go!
Just so we feel like we're there.
Alright, let's see.
I need to interact with bed.
Bed, let me!
I need to be up at 8!
Okay, let's see.
Four hours.
Alright, sleep.
Alright.
Alright, Liam.
Are you ready for another day of hard work, Liam?
In one day!
I could finally afford an employee!
Isn't that crazy?
We have no bathrooms here.
Um...
Let's see.
I'm gonna make sure that we have... Liam!
Do you know how to make coffee?
We can only make three types of coffee.
We can make, um...
all these three coffees!
Liam, do you know how to make coffee?
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
They should arrive any moment now.
I'm gonna supervise.
Now I'm a supervisor.
After one day of working, I have finally decided to be a supervisor.
Oh, flip the sign!
We're open!
Liam's first day of work!
There's...
I swear to fucking...
Okay.
Give me a second.
Alright.
There's one... There's...
Okay.
Alright.
There's one...
Open cashier...
But no, that's okay.
What does Liam do?
What does he do?
I'm literally paying him a hundred dollars!
Okay.
Let's see.
Liam!
Liam, are you working?
Oh my god, Liam's working!
Wait!
Liam's working!
Wait, what was...
Okay, that's three.
Okay.
Um... boom!
Alright.
Okay, don't worry, I'll put the music a little bit up.
Pretty immersiveness.
There we go.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, he's actually working!
He's doing it!
Oh shit, I should... I should grind off.
I don't know what he's doing right now, but like, I think he's...
Wait, is it empty?
Wait, where's my...
Do I not have more?
Where... oh, okay, there we go.
Place.
There we go.
Um...
Alright, and then fill it up.
He's doing it!
I need to hire another barista though!
Okay, 60 and then... pick up.
And then pick up.
Grind, grind, grind, grind, grind.
Oh my god, I can make so much money now!
I can have two at once!
Oh, I need to name you!
What's your name?
Um... your name.
Andre.
Oh shit!
Ah!
Andre!
There we go.
Nice.
And then I'll put that here.
No, that doesn't have anything in it.
Please, I'm so sorry.
Please.
Okay, and then I fill it up.
I'll fill... please Andre, just stay with me.
I just need to make 30 more.
Please, Andre.
Please.
Please don't leave, Andre.
Okay.
Ah, and then I need to throw this away!
Andre, please!
I'm doing my best, Andre!
Okay, and then I fill it up.
Fill, fill, fill, fill.
Fill, fill.
And then...
Put it in.
And then... math.
Andre, we're almost done, Andre.
Please.
We just... we just need...
Andre, please.
Please just wait a little bit longer, Andre.
Oh, I need to grind more coffee beans!
I forgot!
Okay.
Coffee beans.
Fill.
Fill the coffee beans.
Okay.
Grind, grind, grind, grind.
Andre, I'm almost... I unlocked...
What the fuck?
I unlocked what?
What did I unlock?
Okay.
Andre, please.
Wait, is it just... Oh, only two!
Sorry.
Yay!
I did it in advance.
Okay.
Oh, I have an idea!
I'll just leave all these shots here.
So that... um...
So I have them in advance.
Okay.
That's just one.
And then...
I need...
No!
What the...
Okay.
Knock stand.
Knock box.
And then I already grind that up.
So then I just need to pour it... throw it in there.
And then I'll put it in.
And then... BAM!
What's your name?
Chris!
Okay, Chris.
Don't worry, Chris.
I got you.
There you go.
That's Chris in my language.
Alright.
I need... I need another staff.
I... I need another staff member.
Why can't I have two staff members?
Why do I...
Why...
What do you mean I have to upgrade my shop... store again?
What do you mean?
I don't...
Why do we have to upgrade it again?
What if I have another shelf?
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, there's so many people.
Um...
Okay.
What if I...
What...
What if I hire...
Am I level three?
Am I...
Am I... Am I level three?
Is this level three?
Or is it a store?
Is it...
No, we're not in the red!
We have $400!
Uh...
Okay.
And then we fill it up.
Uh... We fill it up right here.
Don't worry, Chris.
I got you.
And... BAM!
Chris is happy.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I...
I need...
I need to upgrade my cafe.
I don't...
Okay.
What does the parking do?
I don't have money.
But, like, I could upgrade warehouse.
Does this...
Does this upgrade my cafe?
My...
Do I have enough to hire?
No!
Mine's still not level three!
I bought it!
What do you want?
You want two orders?!
Um...
Uh...
Expresso...
What...
What is the espresso?
Oh, that's just 30.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, I don't have cups.
I don't...
Oh...
Okay.
Ordered some cups.
And, please...
Please wait.
I don't have cups!
Okay, no... my cafe is starting to get dirty!
No!
It's okay!
Okay, we need to throw this away.
Okay, and then... we gotta put this up.
What do you mean it's empty?
What?
What do you mean?
Did I... Oh, is this already filled?
This is already filled.
Oh, it's already filled.
Oh, I get it.
Where's the delivery guy?
I don't have cups.
I'm sorry!
I... I don't have cups!
I...
I'm sorry!
I don't... We need cups!
Where's... where's Amazon?
Where... where's...
I... Guys, I need cups!
I don't have any cups!
I did!
I ordered cups!
Where's the cups?
I'm a mess!
I'll order more!
Amazon!
Amazon, where are you?
We can't... we can't do anything!
Oh, I should clean.
I should... I should bring out my broom.
How did this place got dirty too?
Okay.
Hey, clean, clean, clean.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Oh, no!
Oh, cargo arrived!
I have cups!
Oh!
Okay.
You can do your order now.
Um... um... oh.
There.
And then... um...
And then... fill.
This is 30, right?
Is this... this is the...
Um... and then... the...
Um... and then...
the...
This is two, right?
Okay.
This is two.
Shock glass.
Boom!
Please wait.
Please wait, sir.
Sir, please.
I got cups.
You are back!
You are... Oh, wait.
No.
You are a different guy.
Sorry.
I thought you reminded me of something.
Okay.
Oh...
Tell... you friends.
There you go.
Alright.
Nice.
Uh... here you go.
Uh...
Okay.
Guys, it's a... it's a coffee shop music.
Are you guys feeling calm from the coffee shop music, guys?
Guys, are you guys... are you guys feeling calm from the coffee shop music?
Is... is it calming you?
No, not at all.
Wait, was that... was that not coffee?
Is that water?
Did I... did I...
Is this not coffee in here?
What's in here?
Please wait a little bit, sir.
I accidentally put... I accidentally put nothing in the filter.
Please.
I didn't... it bugged out.
My coffee shop bugged out.
Okay, I'll put up the sound a little... I'll put it up a little bit more.
Let me know if you're feeling extra immersive.
Guys, please.
It's almost there, sir.
It's almost there.
Just wait a little longer.
You're getting a customer anxiety.
Please.
Please, my dragons.
I used their college tuition, sir.
Please, this is all I have.
You can't leave a negative review.
If you leave a negative review, all 750,000 of my dragons can't go to college.
Okay, we're almost there.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, nice.
We gotta fill it up.
Alright.
Please don't leave.
Please, we're almost... I'm done.
Yay!
I did it!
Three stars?
You can't say best coffee in town and give me three stars!
Okay.
I'm calm.
Wait, I got new... I got new... I got some more cups, guys.
I got... this tree is... I'm having more flashbacks.
Um... I need... I need to invest.
I need to start investing.
Okay, hello, what do you want?
Okay, that's 60.
I just... I just grinded this out, so we should be good.
Alright, and then... fill it up.
You know... It's okay.
Everything... They don't need to be happy.
They're here for coffee.
Oh...
Oh, there we go.
What's your name, sir?
Casey.
Okay, Casey.
Send... help.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where did the... Okay.
We're just gonna put the... Just in case if somebody needs water.
They don't need happiness!
They're here for coffee!
That's enough happiness for them!
That's enough happiness!
Um... What is it?
What time is it?
It's only 6pm?
What do you mean it's only 6pm?
I feel like I've been working for 5 hours already!
Like...
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, and then we got... grinder here.
And we're almost there.
Alright.
We're... We're working so hard.
Okay, pick up.
Alright, fill... Fill it up.
Okay.
Let's keep this... We only have 3 recipes!
Guys, we... We've only unlocked 3 recipes!
That's like the worst part!
We've only unlocked 3 recipes, but I feel like... I feel like it's already 3 too many.
It feels like there's... It feels way too many.
Okay, we're gonna get... We're getting an actual coffee grinder.
And then... And then we're gonna get...
Um...
Okay, we don't... You don't need milk.
Okay, we don't need any of that.
And we don't need this.
So we're gonna get... What's the...
It consists of a filling chamber.
It's making a filter.
Thanks to the filter.
Wait, what?
Why would I need a filter machine?
Okay, we're gonna grab...
The espresso.
Okay, we're broke.
But it's okay.
What do you want?
You want... Okay, 2.
Wait, I just got enough for that.
Okay.
And then... We put it here.
And then we fill it up.
We fill it up.
Guys, we can finally upgrade!
Um... Put it here.
And then...
Boop!
Guys!
We can finally afford an upgrade!
Alright, Danny.
I'm feeling a little... I'm a little confident here.
Yeah!
This is how I feel right now!
I think we can do this!
Guys, I think... Guys, I think...
I think we're like... actual coffee shop owners now.
I'm not stressed anymore.
I... I think I've got the hang... hang of this now.
Alright.
Fill, fill, fill.
Oh.
Oh no, I'm out of coffee.
Um... Um...
Oh, I haven't paid rent at all.
Oh... Okay, I... I just... Oh, it's just $10.
Oh my god, thank god.
Rent is just $10.
Alright, we'll buy some... You know what?
We'll buy 2.
I feel a little adventurous.
Uh... Oh no, is this at 60 yet?
Oh, when is the delivery truck?
Why does the delivery take 2 minutes?
Oh, my coffee shop's a mess!
Okay, um... That's okay.
I feel great.
I still feel great.
I...
I still feel great, guys.
Everything's a-okay.
Yay!
I still... I... I still feel great.
Everything is still okay.
Uh...
Um... Okay, and then now it's closing time.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's start cleaning.
Let's start cleaning the shop a little bit.
We need a...
We need to clean the shop.
Now it's time to clean.
And then...
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Do I have to pay you?
Do you not get automatically paid?
Are you... Why do I have 79%?
The blessed... Is this the best place I've ever seen?
Uh... No, I don't think... I don't... I think he's like automatically paid for.
Right?
Uh... Why would I need parking?
I feel like I don't need any of that.
Alright, that's fine.
It's okay.
My order is here now.
Uh... Alright, let's see.
This is the electric grinder.
Um... One for making coffee is the grinder.
Feel... Okay, nice.
Now I can do it electrically.
Alright, that's good.
That is good.
Um... I don't have to worry about that anymore.
And I think I ordered more cups.
I'm pretty sure.
I think we have more cups.
Yeah, it auto-pays.
Thank God.
Okay, I don't have to worry about paying him.
I gotta remember to place coffee.
We gotta restock our coffee.
I'm just waiting.
Alright, thank you.
Thank you, Amazon.
Alright, and then we place it here.
And then... Place... Place all.
Alright, nice.
We only allow one order of coffee.
Okay, I need a kettle?
Do I...
I don't know if I want a kettle right now.
I don't know.
I don't have an express... Oh, this is an express machine.
Um... And then...
Oh, I can upgrade skills?
Customer greatly increases... I'm more... Oh, I don't want... Please don't come to my store.
Please...
Guys, it's okay.
You don't have to come to my store more.
I have enough customers.
I... I have...
Guys... Guys, it's okay.
I would like more tips though.
I... Oh, unlock tip box!
Yay!
Alright, decorations... Um...
I...
Um... Is that everything?
Oh, I need to fill more coffee.
Okay, I'm gonna like pre-fill coffee.
I'm gonna pre-fill this here.
And then fill this here.
It's 150!
Wait, that's a lot.
Wait, that's so many.
Oh my god, wait, I can do so many things with 150.
Wait, I don't have to grind coffee anymore!
Oh my god, I don't have to grind coffee anymore!
How do I... How do I do this?
Do I just... turn it on?
Oh my god!
I don't have to be a caveman anymore!
Okay, and then...
I'm gonna empty this up.
And...
Fill it up.
Oh, I can only still only fill 30 though.
I... Oh my god, technology.
Oh my god, technology.
Okay, uh, we're gonna...
You know what?
I'm gonna pre-make.
I'm gonna pre-make shots.
Oh my... I figured this out, guys.
Guys, I figured this out.
We pre-make the shots now.
So like, we don't have to worry.
We don't have to worry about... Oh, I need to buy more cups.
Okay, cups.
Uh, let's buy more minis.
Cause like, I don't want you guys to order anything more.
Like, you guys already... We already have too many things.
No, it's okay!
They won't know!
It doesn't tell temperature!
They won't be able to tell!
I guess somebody's like, please, if you're gonna cut corners, wait till day three.
Oh, so it's the music.
It's the co...
It's the...
It's the coffee shop music good enough now?
Alright.
I swear.
Okay, we're gonna experiment.
Okay?
In 94...
Wait, it's going down.
Wait!
No!
Does anyone want cold coffee?
Does any...
I need to be able to afford...
Um...
Uh...
Okay, we need seven hours.
I need to afford a microwave so I can microwave the coffee.
We gotta be able to...
Able to microwave the coffee later.
Um...
Oh, no.
How far is it?
Oh, it's so...
It's so warm!
I knew it!
I knew...
Oh, my God.
We did it.
It's still warm.
Okay, I got it.
Not...
90 Fahrenheit.
Coffee.
So, don't know.
It's still warm.
All right.
And I'll fill it up.
I'll fill it up.
It's still warm.
It's still there.
It's still ready.
We're still ready.
Come in, please!
Somebody!
Somebody come in!
Right now!
Wait, is that Celsius?
It was 7...
There's no way.
There's no way it's 77...
Okay, what do you want?
Oh.
No, that's 60.
Wait, no.
Wait, is it...
Is it like mini...
Wait, what did you want?
Espresso.
No!
You ordered the one thing I don't have!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It was a 30.
Okay.
It was a 30, but that's okay.
That's okay.
It's okay.
The next customer...
The next customer is going to order one.
It's still fine.
We're still fine.
We're so healthy.
What's your name?
Wait, you're Tom.
Okay, you're Tommy.
Okay.
Hot coffee.
There you go.
And then I'll put that here.
And then I don't need to grind anything anymore, so we're fine.
Okay.
Where's my Amazon?
Okay, we need more cups.
We need more cups, though.
We need more cups.
All right.
Bam!
I think we're going to...
We need to make more.
We need to make more money so we can buy a better coffee machine.
So we can make more coffee.
Oh, no.
It's at 63.
Oh, please.
Is it done yet?
Oh, it's done.
Okay.
Which one's the right one?
This one right here.
All right.
Wait, I have two customers?
I have two customers?
Wait.
Why do I have two customers?
You also want an Amazon?
Why do you all want an espresso?
I don't understand.
How do you all want espressos?
All right.
Right here.
Oh, no.
My coffee's not getting hot anymore.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
It's at 56 degrees Celsius now.
No!
Liam, what do I do?
Liam!
My reviews are going down!
Not anymore.
The best barista in town.
Doki, please.
You have to spend your money on actually improving your store, not buying fake reviews.
You can't stop me.
All right.
Here you go.
Oh.
All right.
What's...
Okay.
Um...
I got...
This is how I feel on the inside right now.
Do you want...
What do you want?
You also want an espresso?
Why do you all want espressos?
I don't understand!
All right.
Okay.
We're good.
Um...
We should have more shot glasses.
We have unlimited shot glasses.
This is where we're fine.
Alright.
I'm 200.
Let's see.
Okay, and then we gotta pick your... what's your name?
Neil?
This is how I feel.
Neil, please.
This is how I feel, Neil.
I don't want you to be sad.
Please.
I just want somebody to order...
an order of coffee.
Please.
It's at 35 Celsius.
Alright, 319.
How much do I need to like buy this fancy espresso?
I need like $500 for the fancy espresso.
Oh, but I could get like a coffee filter and open new recipes.
Oh!
Wait, isn't that...
I got one!
It's okay.
One of them might not be as good anymore, but that's okay.
Then we're gonna pick that up and put that here.
I do not get paid to smile.
That's extra.
Okay.
Extra hot coffee.
Coffee.
Oh wait, I can like rotate it.
Now I'm angry, sad.
If you want me to smile, that's extra.
That's...
That's extra.
Oh my god.
Please.
Why can't this machine be faster?
Okay.
Guys, if I was happy, I would not be a barista right now.
Please.
Okay.
Let's see.
We fill it up.
All right.
This is fine.
We're making money.
We're making good progress.
This is absolutely fine.
Yeah, he's happy.
Okay.
All right.
My reviews are back to 80.
Best place I've ever seen.
When you want.
Okay.
That's it.
That's two.
How much more?
Okay.
I need to put more coffee in here.
Give me a sec, ma'am.
I need to put more coffee in the... in this grinder.
It's okay.
We ordered two.
So we should have enough.
Right?
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Guys, I know like we haven't made any like actual profit and we're still investing in the store, but that's okay.
It's a long game here.
Um, and then, um, we got to put this away.
And then put this in.
And put that in here.
And I still have plenty of shot glasses, guys.
Bam!
There we go!
Oh, wait.
I should pour the rest of this coffee in here too.
Uh, all right.
All right.
That's fine.
Okay.
What's your name?
Eva.
Get in.
Oh, what the fuck?
That's your twin.
Wait.
What?
What the fuck?
Triplets?
Wait.
They're all the...
What?
Wait.
Okay.
There's a glitch in the matrix.
There is.
I think there's a glitch in the matrix, guys.
All right.
Um.
It's okay.
One of the triplets is having a good time.
One of the triplets got their order.
Why did you line up on my side?
We have a barista.
All right.
Okay.
Um.
Wait.
Did you...
Um.
Wait.
Whose coffee is this?
Is this your coffee?
Wait.
Then whose coffee is this?
I'm so...
Why do I have...
Why do I have two?
I'm so...
Why do I have...
Why do I...
Why do I have two cups?
I don't know.
I don't know why I have two cups.
Okay.
That's...
That's a lot of shots.
Okay.
And then we put that in here.
And then we fill this up.
But like when did I...
When did I have a...
When did I have a second...
A second one?
When...
When did I...
Guys, my brain is breaking.
When did that happen?
I don't remember.
Okay.
We're going to get the expensive one.
We can afford the expensive espresso machine.
We need the expensive...
This is faster.
What does he want?
He also wants an espresso and this is a triplo.
So like I need two shot glasses.
I have more shot glasses in here.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
Everything...
Wait.
Why is he angry?
Okay.
I don't understand.
Why are you angry?
What...
What did I do?
I...
I don't understand.
Why was he angry?
He didn't want to wait.
We have two lines.
Okay.
Sarah, please don't be angry.
I'm just an anime girl.
Sarah, please.
Why are you angry?
Please don't be angry, this anime girl is gonna cry!
Let's see what we need.
Okay, and now we got press 2.
Please, please Nathan, please!
I'm trying my best, Nathan!
Nathan, please don't be angry at me!
I'm gonna cry!
Your cafe is starting to get dirty.
What do you want me to do?
I'm just one person!
It's just me and Liam!
If you don't like it, just leave!
Just leave my cafe!
I already have too many customers!
I have too many customers!
I don't need all of you here!
Okay.
We got this.
Alright.
Oh wait, did I pour everything in?
Okay, I think I did.
Okay.
Oh, thank God!
Alright, what do you want?
You want an espresso?
Okay, the espresso is easy!
Expresso is easy!
Okay.
Alright, we gotta fill it up!
We gotta fill it up!
What day is it today?
3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
Oh my god, there's still 4 more hours of work!
There's still... Okay, that's okay.
What did you want?
That's... That's 1.
1.
Okay.
Boom.
Oh, our other... Our other one is here.
It's okay, we have... We have...
We have the better coffee machine!
Okay, we're gonna put the better coffee machine here.
Alright, nice.
And then... We're gonna put that here.
And then...
Are you... Oh shit!
What's your name, sir?
Nathan!
Don't worry, Nathan!
Asshole.
There we go.
That's you.
That's fucking right, Nathan.
I called you out.
You made me wanna cry.
That's fucking right.
I hope you know what you are.
Alright, espresso.
I wanna use my new machine!
Okay, how do I use my new machine?
Wait, it's still 30?
Wait, do I have no more?
Wait, what?
Is there no more in there?
Is that it?
Is that actually it?
Wait, how do I... How do I put this on?
What the fuck?
What did you do, Liam?
I'm so confused.
Wait.
They're not grind... Oh, I didn't grind it yet!
Okay.
Fill it.
And I'll fill the rest of this here.
And then... um...
How do I... put it on?
How do I put this on?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, where's my other...
Wait, what happened to my other... grinder?
Wait, where did my electric grinder go?
Did it glitch out?
Wait!
My electric grinder's gone!
My electric grinder!
No!
Oh my god.
Oh, it's in my inventory.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna freak out.
I was actually...
Not to do this again!
It refunded my car!
Liam, you fucker!
No!
Liam!
Sir?
Oh no, I don't have enough beans!
Do I have enough beans?
Oh, I do.
Oh my god, Liam sabotaged...
I can't do this again!
Okay.
Guys, guys, please.
I'm sorry.
I...
Oh no, my reviews.
Okay.
I need more coffee.
No, I will get through you.
Um, please, give up.
Why are you crying?
I'm gonna be crying first before you.
Like...
Hahaha!
Like, why are you crying?
Is it... does it finish grinding?
Is it done?
Oh, I think it's done.
Okay.
Okay, and then we'll fill this.
I think that's 30 at that point.
No, do I not have enough?
Do I...
Do I not have enough in there?
Do I not have enough?
What happened?
Okay.
Um, and then...
What did you want?
You wanted triplo.
Oh...
Um...
I'm sorry, I'm...
Please, Liam!
Please!
Leave me alone!
Liam!
What are you...
Liam...
Stop, Liam!
There's nothing in there!
Why is there nothing in there?
Why is there...
Why is there water?
Is there anything...
What?
Why is there water?
I thought I put...
Oh my god!
I thought I...
I'm sorry, please, sir.
I don't have coffee.
I'm sorry.
I ran out of coffee.
Okay.
Alright.
Please, if you can wait 25 more seconds.
Please.
Things are getting really out of hand.
If you can wait 25 more seconds, please.
Wait, the other garbage bag is gone.
Oh, it works!
We just leave it outside.
Please.
Please, sir.
Let me...
Do you want to talk?
Sir?
Like, if we talk, then like, things can be fine.
Cargo arrived.
Oh my god, we have more coffee.
We have more coffee.
Oh, that's so good.
We have...
We actually...
We actually have more coffee.
Oh, alright.
Um...
And then we gotta place all our coffee here.
Place all...
And then...
Um...
Where's our grinder?
Okay, we fill our grinder up.
Please, sir.
Just wait...
Just wait a little bit longer.
Please don't leave.
Sir, please.
Please, just...
Just wait like five more minutes, sir.
I'm doing my best.
I'm...
I'm doing my absolute best.
I'm doing my absolute best right now.
Okay, and then...
Then we're gonna put these here.
And I think it's done filling.
Okay, and then we're gonna fill it up here.
And I'm just gonna keep blending it.
I think that worked.
And grind, grind, grind, and it was triplo, right?
Triplo.
Okay.
I think I'm wearing shot glasses here.
And here we go.
Boom!
We're making coffee!
Please, just stay with us for a little longer.
Please just stay with us a little longer.
I'm gonna write your name.
What's your name?
Herman!
Herman, that's your name.
Alright, there you go.
Is it filled?
Okay.
We filled this up.
Herman, please stay with me.
Stay with me a little longer.
How is this faster?
This is not faster at all.
Please.
How is this faster?
Herman!
Herman's still here!
Herman's still with us!
Thank you, Herman!
Happy customer!
Alright.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Okay.
And then... garbage.
Boop.
Alright.
Nice.
Guys, I think opening a coffee shop was a mistake.
I think...
Guys, I don't think this was the right idea.
I don't think this was the right idea.
Let me clean this first before.
Okay.
I cleaned this.
And then I will put you here.
And then I cleaned... I cleaned this.
And... oh, the container's full already?
Okay.
I need to pick it up.
Throw it in.
And...
And then...
Clean...
Clean.
Okay, and then I need to...
Guys...
Guys, I don't think anybody, any of us are going back to college.
I don't...
I need, I need a filter machine.
I need to buy that.
And I'm gonna... I bought a filter, so now we have more recipes.
We got filtered coffee!
Coffee!
Made by brewing hot water over coffee grounds and letting the resulting drip through a filter.
How do you do that?
How do you, how do you, how do you do that?
What, what does that mean?
Guys, I want to upgrade.
I want to get a bathroom, guys.
Guys, I think my plan, it's perfect.
I'm gonna have you guys, I'm gonna have you guys...
None of you guys are getting colleges, so you're forced to work here in my coffee shop until we pay things off.
Until I don't...
Hmm.
Oh my god, I can increase the cargo price and then...
Let's see, more customers will leave positive reviews.
Oh my god, I can buy more bots to leave positive reviews on my store?
Wait, that sounds great!
Um...
Let's see.
What's a thousand connector?
Your cafe can work one additional...
No, that is okay.
I already work too much here.
I...
That's okay.
I think I work more than enough in this cafe.
I'm just gonna sit here to wait for our shop to give me more stuff.
Oh my god.
Now, now I know why.
Oh, now I know why people were like, Like, this game is really stressful.
Now I understand.
I laughed about it.
But oh my god.
Why did I laugh about it?
Okay, I want most important materials.
I want a coffee shop.
Alright, how do I do this?
Coffee grind.
Coffee filter paper.
What?
Do I just...
pour?
I pour this.
I pour that.
And then...
pour?
Pour?
What?
Filter paper?
Oh filter paper!
I'm so confused.
I need...
My cat needs to sleep!
I need to pour more beans though.
Oh, because it's already crushed.
Alright.
Alright guys, we gotta...
No, we don't have material.
Okay, we're gonna sleep a little bit.
We're gonna sleep until 6.
So then we have time to figure this out.
Alright, save.
Save.
And then...
We're gonna sleep...
2 hours?
2 hours.
Alright, that should be enough.
Oh, our stuff has arrived!
Nice!
Oh my god, it's only day 3.
It's only...
We should not have had 3 wifi.
We should not.
Free wifi was a mistake.
Um...
Where did the filter paper go?
Filter paper?
Oh, filter paper!
Okay, and then...
Coffee?
And then...
Bean?
No?
Bean don't go inside?
Bean?
Oh!
Bean...
Yes, I figured it out.
Guys...
I figured out where the beans go.
Oh my god, we already got a big coffee!
Coffee!
Okay, grind.
We have to watch this grind now.
We still have lots of time.
Alright.
I became bad at language.
Because...
Because paper is just really hard.
I didn't know... Wait, do I need water?
Do I need water in the coffee mug?
Or is that good to go?
Are we good to go?
Do I need water?
Oh my god, okay.
How do I fill it up?
I fill it up with shot glasses?
No?
How do I...
How do you fill up water?
Water go where?
Water...
Um...
Why is water not going?
What?
Water please...
Why is...
Why can't I fill it up?
Water machine?
Water?
What?
Um...
Maybe if I...
Maybe...
Uh...
Water here?
No?
Read the recipe.
Filter coffee is made by pouring hot water over coffee grounds and letting the resulting brew drip through...
What?
I need a kettle!
You need a kettle?
Are you fucking...
Okay, you can fill it while it's here.
It has a large...
Most coffee calls...
You need this machine.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you...
Okay.
Alright.
I need a kettle.
It didn't tell me I need a kettle when we had the recipe!
As no one comes to the coffee shop expecting it to be clean.
That's all I'm gonna say.
No, all I drink is canned coffee.
Guys, don't make me bring this right now.
I swear to God if I hear one more critique on my store.
I swear to God, Nathan.
I swear to fucking God.
I'll do it.
I'll fucking do it.
Espresso... okay.
Um... alright, let's see.
We need to... alright.
We gotta grab that here.
And then... poop.
And then we gotta grab that here.
And this here.
Bam.
Alright, and then...
What's your name again?
What's your name?
Nathan.
Okay.
Tip me, please.
Or... I'll... cry.
Oh yeah, you had two orders.
Give me a sec.
Alright, there you go.
Two orders.
I think that one's done.
Okay.
And then...
That's your order.
And then this is also your order.
Right here.
That pour in the ca- okay, I thought I poured it in another shot glass.
Because I've done that before.
Bam!
Alright, what do you want?
You want an espresso.
Oh, an espresso!
That's easy to do.
Oh, I can't find an easier way for this.
An espresso.
Heart.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got you.
It would be nice if this should tip my coffee.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I should have a kettle now!
I have a kettle!
Guys, I got a kettle!
How do I do this?
Okay.
And then I just pour the water.
Okay, that seems easy.
Fill.
Alright, let's fill this with 350 right off the bat.
You forgot my- Nathan!
Nathan, leave!
Leave the store!
You'll come back anyway because I'm the closest coffee shop to your house.
I could treat you like this because you're not gonna walk another block for your coffee.
You know you need this store more than this store needs you.
Alright, let's see what's for her.
Alright, here you go.
And then we're gonna put this on the stove.
And then, poof.
Alright, what do you want?
Why are you on my line?!
We don't have medium- There's medium coffee cups now?!
We have other sizes?!
No, we have other sizes.
Why are you crying?
Oh, because you don't have much to live?
And you're wasting the majority of your remaining license?
You're just standing here waiting for your fucking coffee?!
Good!
Wait, does it have beans?
Does it have- Yeah, it does.
Okay, it does have beans.
Um, mini espresso.
Yay!
Alright.
Um... let's see.
Here we go.
And then...
We gotta pick it up.
Wait, I thought they're not?
Is it ready?
Container- Oh, container's full!
Okay, let's pick that up.
And then... we'll put that here.
And... we have $95?!
What did I spend?!
Oh, I spent it on... Oh, I remember.
I spent it on...
Uh... I spent it on... uh...
More cups.
Only I'm allowed- Exactly.
Only I'm allowed to cry in my coffee shop.
You think you're better than me just because you're here using my services?!
Okay.
Um...
What's your name?
Lola!
Hello, Lola!
This is the one time you- I gave a normal name on this- on this coffee cup.
Alright.
Alright, here you go.
Let's sh- Alright.
Alright, Lola.
Oh, hello, Granny.
You want filtered coffee?
I don't even have a small!
Oh my gosh, it's 30 more seconds.
Um...
Um... Okay, we're gonna...
Wait, what does she want?
Americano?
I have an Americano?!
How the fuck do you make an Americano?!
Espresso and water.
Oh, okay, so you just want watered coffee.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I don't have- Amazon's coming!
Okay, thank god!
Okay, Amazon's here.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, I have cups now.
Um...
Small coffee.
Okay, what do you- how do I- small filter- how do I make filtered coffee again?
I- How do I- how do I make filtered coffee?
Um, fil- filtered coffee, 236 milliliters.
Oh!
No!
That's not what I want!
Alright, let's see.
Filtered coffee!
Um...
Lid?
Is this- is this hot enough?
It's still not hot enough?
Wait, why is the water going down?
Oh, it's evaporating!
It's-
Wait - Oh...
How do I...
How do I put water inside?
How do I fill it?
Does that...
How do I...
How do I fill it?
How do I fil- Fill the water!
How do I- how do I fill this?
How do I...
Is it filling?
Is it doing anything?
Is your coffee going in there?
I can't tell.
It's just Steve.
Coffee is going in!
Oh my god, it's working!
Okay, what do you want?
Americano.
Americano, you need...
At least Liam is picking up the slack.
Americano.
Can I take it off of... okay.
What size?
What size Americano?
Big!
Why do you need a big Americano?
120 expresso.
120 expresso?!
Just leave.
Just leave my store.
Please.
Um...
Small.
What?
How much small filtered coffee?
Small.
354?!
I don't...
Do I have 354?
I... I'm fucking...
Leave.
That was my... NOOOOO!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA Ssssshhhh.
It's okay.
I'll buy another review.
It's okay, guys.
I bought another review to balance things out.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I bought another review so it's like it never happened.
It's like it never happened guys.
They beat me.
Five stars.
Thanks guys for balancing it out.
Wait, what is it?
A mini.
Oh thank god it's a mini.
Thank god.
Anytime I see a mini I'm like oh thank you.
Oh thank you.
Liam please move.
I can't see.
I can't see Liam.
What's your name?
Oh it's Lola you came back.
Lola.
Lola you came back Lola.
Alright.
Lola.
Lola is my best customer.
I think Lola is the best one so far.
She likes being mistreated.
He's working Liam.
I'm alone.
Your cafe is starting to get dirty.
It's been like it's 84%.
That's like that's at least passable.
By like the safety inspector.
As long as the safety inspector does not complain.
I do not need to clean my cafe.
I do not need to clean anything.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay.
That's good.
Okay Lola.
What do you want?
You want a...
Oh my god.
You left a cigarette box in my...
Oh please.
How much do I need to do to upgrade?
I need 200 more.
As soon as I get 200 dollars.
I can...
I can have another barista I think.
I think so.
Is that enough of an upgrade?
How much is security?
2500.
Why would I need more security?
Like why would I need more?
I don't understand.
Okay.
Uh...
Then we fill it up.
We need to grind some more coffee.
Uh... alright.
Grind some coffee.
And then fill it up.
Fill it up.
Alright guys.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Like I don't understand why I need more security.
Because I feel like...
I feel like...
I haven't been robbed yet.
Oh my god.
Am I gonna get robbed?
Why would you want to rob this place?
I don't even have a working bathroom.
Like...
What is there?
What is there to rob?
I don't even have working toilets.
I just have expensive overpriced coffee.
This is worse than Supermarket Simulator.
I can't say it.
This is so much worse.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I need to unlock the bathroom.
Alright.
Let's see.
We need to put this here.
Put this here.
And then we're grabbing new shot glass.
Oh my god.
This isn't even a nice coffee.
I literally bought the beans from Walmart.
Why are you all still here?
Who keeps leaving good reviews?
I just wanted to be like an indie coffee shop.
Why is there three of you now?
Who keeps recommending my coffee shop?
It's supposed to be like indie.
We're supposed to be hipster.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh no.
I need...
Okay.
I need to grab...
Am I 16?
Not yet.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Who keeps recommending us?
What's your name?
Um...
Betong.
Wait.
Did you want Minnie?
Minnie.
Okay.
Uh...
Leave.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
And then...
Where's my other shot glass?
Here we go.
Alright.
There you go.
Pour.
Word of mouth.
Who keeps recommending?
Stop!
Stop word of mouthing this coffee shop!
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm an actor.
I pretend to get beaten.
Really interesting idea.
Coffee shop.
Minnie express.
So that was one, right?
That's one.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh...
Here we go.
Pure.
And then...
Pour this in.
Uh... This coffee shop was good before it became popular.
Thank you for the super chat, Minnie.
Thank you.
Your caff... Oh, I don't have...
I don't have a shot glass in here.
Okay.
Guys, when do I get to unlock other...
Please.
I...
I just wanna... I wanna unlock the...
Please.
Please calm down, everybody.
Please calm down.
I'm not even...
No, Liam!
Where did Liam go?
Liam!
Why aren't you working faster, Liam?
Oh.
Um...
We're doing too well.
Please leave more negative reviews, guys.
Please leave more negative reviews.
We have too many people in the shop!
Leave negative reviews!
Don't come back!
Please!
Oh, thank God.
Thank God they heard me.
Leave...
Okay.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God they're actually leaving.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Alright.
Last customer of the day.
Okay.
Yay!
I missed when they gave me $90 per coffee.
Oh, they're ordering the cheapest coffee!
That's why!
What the fuck?
They're so cheap!
Oh, I need a... I need clean.
Clean, clean, clean.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Okay, um...
Okay, and then we gotta pick up the cigarette boxes and the cigarettes.
Who keeps smoking in my coffee shop?
It literally says no smoking!
Who's smuggling smokes?
In my coffee shop!
I know the trash can's over here, but I've been trying to see if I can collect trash bags up back here.
Nobody can tell anyway!
Nobody can tell!
Liam, Liam, are you smoking in my coffee shop?
What are you stressed out about?
I'm the one... Oh my god, he has to do two orders.
Okay.
Let's see...
What are you stressed out about, Liam?
You had less customers to deal with than me!
Do I have anything coffee in here?
Wait, what?
Did it not throw away the coffee?
Oh, it's the containers!
Oh, okay.
Alright, the trash bags.
And then...
And then we put that in.
And then we fill it up.
Give Liam a...
No!
Nobody deserves break in this coffee shop!
None of us deserves it!
If I'm gonna be unhappy, my workers...
Okay.
Everybody has to be unhappy.
Nobody can feel joy in this coffee shop.
That's just the way it is.
Why are you still working, Liam?
Where's the coffee?
The priest is really busy.
Please leave her alone.
I can't...
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Liam!
Where the fuck is this guy's coffee?
Where is this guy's coffee?
Liam.
Liam, where is the coffee?
Happy Leo!
Leo gets $100 a day and he has 3 kids with 3 different ladies.
Leo smokes.
Thank you for the super chat, Ted.
Thank you.
Leo!
Morgan is crying!
How hard is it to get a fucking Americano?
I'm starting to think that Doki is cut out to be a barista.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
What are you talking about?
I'm a great barista owner!
We're gonna get toilets soon!
Liam, please!
It's almost midnight, Liam!
We closed 3 hours ago!
How are you... I'm fucking leaving.
Fuck this shit.
I'm gonna fucking go to bed.
I gotta go to bed.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm only on day 4.
How have I played this game for 2 hours already?
There's no fucking way!
I played this game for 2 hours?
Holy shit!
I feel like I've...
Oh my god!
It did not feel like 2 hours!
Okay...
Alright...
Um...
What do we need?
I already...
Okay, I put coffee grounds already over here.
And then...
Alright...
We have 2 more hours.
Um...
We're gonna order more coffee just in case.
Just in case, I feel like.
Order.
I feel like we definitely need more.
Um...
Let's see...
We don't need milk yet.
So, we're gonna need...
We're gonna need...
Oh, I can sell supplies or food?
Wait...
I could've done that?
Okay, we need toilets first though.
We definitely need toilets first.
We're so close to toilets.
We need $200.
Um...
I wanna sleep for 2 more hours so we can open up.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki doing overtime on gaming like she doesn't game.
Alright, we just need like...
2 more hours and then that should be good.
Alright, Liam, you live here.
You don't even get to sleep.
You don't get to go home and see your family.
You live here until you pay off my debt.
You need this job more than you need anything else and you know that.
You're here forever fucking ever.
Um...
So, all of those things are here.
Let's see, okay.
We should be able to open.
You're never gonna see your family again until I pay off all my... all the debt I have.
Alright, what does he want?
We want filtered coffee and big americano.
How much is the filtered again?
Filtered coffee.
Medium, right?
437.
Filtered... wait, is it medium?
Okay, big americano.
Alright, 28 degrees of coffee.
That is fine by me.
Wait, how many was it, guys?
Guys, I already forgot.
How many was it?
Guys, how many was it?
Guys, how many was it again?
I read it but now I forgot.
Guys...
Was it 420?
Okay, I'm fucking reading this.
Uh, filtered medium.
400...
Oh, it's a filter.
It's full.
Okay, it's full.
Alright, 473.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
470.
We just have to fill it all the way up.
So we should be good.
Alright, 473.
That's the medium, right?
Yeah.
That's the medium.
Guys, don't worry.
We're gonna heat this up, guys.
I have a plan.
I have a huge plan.
Guys, I didn't even have to buy a kettle.
I can't believe you guys told me to buy a kettle.
I didn't even need the kettle!
And the water originally already came!
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna put this away.
So I can put...
Oh, I can't.
I can't put the... I can't fucking heat up my...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Calm down.
Big Americano.
Uh-huh.
471 and one espresso.
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
And then I'll just put that back on.
Um...
Where's the big?
Where's big?
Okay.
Big.
Bitch.
Alright.
Let's see.
And then we're gonna grab this.
And we're gonna fill it up.
We're gonna fill it up!
473!
Uh-huh.
It's okay.
Wait, it was water.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking...
This is what I needed the kettle for.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Wait, how do I put water in here?
What?
What do I...
What do I pour water?
Wait.
Is it normal water?
Oh, normal water.
Wait.
Tap water?
Okay, that does not sound right.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
What?
Wait.
Tap water?
It's...
Okay, we're gonna put it all the way here.
Okay.
473.
Wait, I should put the shot in first.
Oh my god, you're right.
Oh shit.
It's okay.
He's still here.
All right, we got that in.
And then...
And then we put water in.
All right, nice.
And then that should be 473.
I got plus 10 popularity.
Please, why is my cafe still...
still is so popular?
I don't...
Please.
All right.
All right, guys.
You're gonna get some nice, juicy tap water coffee.
Oh no, man.
I don't feel good about using...
Oh, whatever.
Who cares what I feel?
Like, cool.
Wait.
I don't...
I don't think this is correct.
Oh, it's all right.
He'll be fine.
He's still happy.
It's a freezing place... who asked you?
Oh, I can buy a toilet!
I just have a little extra water.
It's just a little extra.
Alright, nice.
Do I have...
Do I have another barista now?
I have a bathroom, guys!
Oh, God.
Okay.
Oh, the bills.
You're right.
There you go.
What do you want?
Americano?
Don't worry, man.
Okay, Americano.
I need...
Okay, I don't want to do another coffee here.
So I'm just going to do it here.
Boom.
Okay, that's like...
What is the Americano again?
That was like...
Uh...
Oh, 120 espresso.
Oh!
Oh, I gave him less coffee!
But like, he was happy though.
You know what?
That's fine.
I gave him less coffee, but he was still happy.
You know?
Like, they don't know.
They're too stupid for that.
Yeah.
They're too...
They don't know!
It's just...
It was fun!
He didn't notice!
I told you guys!
Like, these people don't know anything about like regular coffee!
They don't know anything!
They can't tell!
They order the drink and they're just satisfied!
They don't know!
They don't know jack shit!
Why are you here at the coffee shop?
Alright, let's put that at 400.
Alright, and then...
Where's my other...
Um...
Oh, that's just water.
Eh.
Um...
No!
She knew!
This is not coffee!
I should have put espresso.
God damn!
I should have put espresso!
Oh, there's so many...
There's so many people that want so many...
Coffee!
I'm done!
It's over.
Get over here.
I don't have any...
It's over.
Get out.
Get out!
I'm done!
Hey, my popularity increased.
Yeah.
Alright.
Guys, being a barista is really hard.
Guys.
I don't...
I don't want to be a barista anymore.
Why not?
I think...
I think I'm...
I think I'm ready to close up my shop.
I think...
Okay, I got...
Hey, guys.
I got...
I got more coffee, guys.
Hey.
And your coffee arrived.
Yay.
Hey guys!
I restocked.
Oh my god!
I restocked!
Shady, thank you for the aqua soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, moi moi coon, for my double espresso caro macchiato with whipped cream and chocolate sprinkles on top!
With a breakfast croissant!
I can give you this!
No, I can't hit Liam!
I can't hit Liam!
Alright guys, it's...
announcement time.
Let me swap over.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I can't...
I thought... you know...
I don't know... I thought...
Barista Simulator...
would be okay...
But I didn't realize...
I didn't realize...
how not okay I was.
I was... I was...
I was absolutely not okay.
Shoutout to all the baristas out there.
Shoutout to you guys.
I can't last longer than five days being a barista.
I cannot.
I...
I thought... I was like...
It's just coffee!
How hard can making coffee be?
There's like hundreds of Tim Hortons out there.
How hard can it be?
There's so...
so many like indie coffee shops where all the hipsters go.
Like... Surely like...
It can't be that difficult.
Oh my god.
I was so wrong.
I had like five orders.
I have five items on my menu.
I haven't even gotten to the lattes.
I haven't gotten to the milk yet.
I haven't...
I haven't even gotten to the milk portion of the recipe.
Why was this so difficult?
There was just...
There was just five recipes!
Darkblade do not call Tim Hortons coffee, please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
People still buy Tim Hortons over making their own coffee.
That's all I'm saying.
Oh my god.
We were only at the beginning of the game, but it was so much.
It was so much.
Holy shit.
Anyway.
Anyway guys.
Alright.
Whoa.
I'm really nervous about some of these announcements.
But...
Let me stretch before I do it.
Wow!
Alright.
So.
This announcement sort of already got leaked out.
Because I saw people that were like, oh my god.
Is this the... Is this...
actually Doki?
So like, some of you guys already know this announcement because it got leaked out.
And then it got like posted somewhere.
So then people were like, oh my god.
So I thought it was really... But I couldn't confirm or deny it until like today.
So.
Alright.
There's actually... There's also one of the things that...
Oh my gosh.
It has been on my goals list for a very long time.
It's been on the goals list for a long time.
So...
I said like...
out of...
I'm like super, super nervous.
But like...
I feel... You guys already know what the announcement... I like how I'm wearing my barista uniform.
Okay guys.
Let me take off my barista uniform.
And my brace.
Let me...
Give me a sec.
I need to take off my uniform first.
If I'm gonna do this announcement.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Let me...
Alright.
My uniform is off now.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Sorry.
I'm like super... I'm super duper nervous.
But... I will show the graphic first.
Why I'm like... I'm like...
Yay!
This is actually one of my dreams.
One of my dreams.
So I'm really, really, really, really excited.
Okay guys.
Sorry.
I realized I need to move away a little bit.
I'm gonna...
Let me like move first.
Let me move a little bit first guys.
Okay.
For real now.
For real.
For...
For real now.
But this this announcement has been leaked earlier.
Because some people saw a particular thing on a pamphlet.
And it is... Ta-da!
I'm going to be at ACG HK.
In Hong Kong.
I've always thought this would never happen for me.
Because...
For those who don't know...
ACG HK is the biggest convention in Hong Kong.
And...
This has been...
This has been like my number one convention.
That I wanted to do in my career.
And I always thought that like...
It was never possible.
That I didn't have a lot of fans.
Um...
To make it possible.
And I thought I wasn't like popular enough in Hong Kong to do this.
Because...
ACG HK is like... basically like the Comic Con for NA.
And...
ACG HK is like the Comic Con of Hong Kong.
So...
It is a huge honor to be invited.
Um...
And... This is like one of my dream conventions.
Uh... To be invited to this convention.
Because...
Uh... ACG HK was like my very first convention.
As a child.
Like... It was the very first convention I ever went to.
Um... And...
You know... I had like a lot of very happy memories going there.
Like...
For like a couple of years.
Um... And... I spent a lot of money.
At ACG HK.
And... It's like...
Um... Honestly like...
Uh... The big... One of the biggest honors to have and to be invited.
Um... To be invited for this year.
For it.
Um...
And yeah.
This is like literally my dream convention.
So I'm really thankful for them to invite me.
I'll be at the main stage!
Yes!
I will be at the main stage.
So...
The main stage panel.
It's already...
The leak was that they released a pamphlet.
Of the schedule.
And people saw like... Uh... Doki's Hong Kong Adventures on there.
And they were like...
Is that the real Doki?
In the pamphlet?
Yes!
That is me!
I...
That was me on the...
That is me!
So people couldn't tell.
Couldn't tell if it was like... Uh...
If it was like me or like some other Doki.
Uh...
Anyway.
So I will be at the main stage.
And... Um...
There's gonna be games, a Q&A, and some... Yeah.
Some like mini games and a panel.
Um...
And it's free to watch.
Basically.
So for like those in Hong Kong.
Um... It is free to watch.
You don't have to pay any tickets.
But they are releasing five types of merch.
Uh...
Including a new Hong Kong style key visual.
And details of that will be announced soon.
So there's gonna be like five months.
So I'm gonna be able to get some merch created just for regarding uh... Regarding this convention.
And I'll also be hosting a uh... Meet and Greet for this session.
Um... And basically if you buy the bundle set of my merch, you can join the Meet and Greet.
Uh... Before my main stage panel.
So...
Uh... Or like panel, mini games, and everything.
So that is... Uh...
So you buy the bundle merch, you basically will be able to do a Meet and Greet.
But there is a max number.
So it is like first come first serve when it comes to um...
When it comes to uh... this uh... Meet and Greet in Hong Kong.
And uh... Oh my gosh.
I'm just so... I'm just really, really happy because this is like I said, this is like one of my dream goals to accomplish.
Like I remember in the past when I was like... The one convention that I really, really, really wanna go was ACTHK.
And I honestly... I always thought that like I was just not popular than I was.
I was not popular enough in Hong Kong.
Um... To be it, but it was just...
I was proven wrong!
I was...
I...
I was... I was proven wrong!
All my fans were like, that's not true Doki!
We want you there!
We want you...
We wanna meet you!
Um...
So I'm really happy.
I'll be speaking Cantonese.
I'll try to be speaking Cantonese.
So I'll try my best.
I'm like...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna try my best to speak Cantonese.
And...
Oh my gosh.
Funny story.
But like... They were like...
Please don't swear because there's children.
So I will try not to swear!
I'm gonna try very hard to be PG!
I'm gonna try so hard to be PG!
I mean...
This will be the hardest mission ever.
Gotta stay PG!
For the children!
For the children Doki!
Um...
Another thing is that I will be at...
Um... This isn't like the only appearance that I'll be making in Hong Kong.
Um... I will be at Yu-san's concert.
Uh... So... Um...
So that will be a week after ACGHK.
And... Basically it is an independent event in Hong Kong.
Sorry I have like... I need to remember... Like...
Stuff I have to remember to say about it because there's a lot of details.
And there will be a fan support zone where like fans can start basically a fan campaign for me and Yu-san.
And...
I will be performing um... with Yu-san.
Uh... For this concert.
It's like basically a week after ACGHK.
And... We did prepare some secret content there too.
Not just the song.
And...
Um...
I'm just so excited.
I...
I really am.
This is actually...
Uh... Like I said, it's a world tour!
It's a world tour.
And we added so many destinations on this world tour.
Uh...
To be able to meet you guys.
Meet all the dragoons and everything.
And I'm honestly... I'm just...
I... I'm just so excited to uh... Meet dragoons around the world!
And to be able to announce the Hong Kong edition as well.
Um... And...
Like... You know, being able to do a convention that was basically like my...
My very first ever convention that I've ever went to as a child.
And just...
And then being on the main stage now.
That's...
That's... That's a lot.
It's something that...
You know... I never expected at all to happen in my life.
So I'm super thankful.
And...
I'm just... I'm just really happy.
And... To be able to have this opportunity with all of you guys.
Um... Okay!
This is not the last... We have an announcement for...
So now some of you guys are like, so what is tomorrow's secret stream?
Um...
Okay!
This is also another dream!
That I never thought would be a reality!
So...
We literally like finalized the details for this.
Like... This morning.
So... Um... I was like...
That's why I was like, oh I don't know if like...
Tomorrow I can even do this secret stream because like we're still negotiating details about what I'm supposed to be doing and everything.
Um...
So... We literally finalized all the details this morning.
So... I can finally announce it!
And it's not a secret anymore!
And... Um...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let me... I need to get the graphics.
I need to get the graphics in.
But...
The moment I get the graphics in, you guys are gonna be like... Oh my god!
You're all gonna be like...
Oh my god!
Basically...
Drum roll please!
Yeah!
To celebrate!
Neopets 25th Anniversary!
We'll be doing a sponsored stream with Neopets!
Um...
They have announced a new storyline.
A new plot.
Uh...
And storyline.
Regarding... Uh...
To celebrate its 25th Neopets Anniversary.
And we're gonna be looking through the website and looking through the new plot line.
And the new comic series that's based off the new plot.
Um...
So I'm super excited.
Uh... I'm really really excited.
Uh... To show you... Showcase it to you guys.
It's called The Void Within.
And... Oh my gosh!
I remember looking through like...
The plot.
Like the plots they would have.
And like the guy... Like the little storylines they would have and everything.
The lore.
Um...
Neopets.
Um... The one with like the... The Neopets Atlantis.
Was it Mar... Mar... I don't know how to pronounce it cause I would always read the names.
But the... The...
Mar... Marroquan or what?
Haha!
The Marro... The Marroquan I could never pronounce the name of the lands.
But there was that one.
And there was the one with the Altador.
The Altator.
Secret Altadors.
And then that led to like the Olympics of Neopets.
And then there was one with the Daragon Kingdom.
And then there's the other... Oh my god.
There were so many.
The one with Dr. Sloth.
Oh my gosh.
But they have a new plotline!
They have a new plotline!
Called The Void Within!
And it is gonna be sponsored by Neopets to celebrate their 25th anniversary.
Um... I'm super duper duper duper duper duper excited uh... to...
uh... to be able to do this with Neopets as a collaboration.
And I hope to have more future collabs with them.
Yeah!
It was great working with them on this.
Um... They were like what's your favorite Neopets?
And I like gave them a huge giant list.
And then we're like okay we'll see what we can do here.
We got it!
Um... But yes!
That is what tomorrow's stream gonna be about!
Um... It is a Neopets centric stream.
And uh...
Like I said it's just... It's to look... uh...
They... They asked me to look at The Void Within.
But most likely I'll also be looking at other stuff too.
I might even go over time than what they paid me.
Because like I love Neopets.
And I can't believe I'm being paid for... I'm being paid for to play a... a childhood game that I invested like a lot lot of hours as a kid.
So that's so crazy to think about!
And like they're paying me to play their... to play their website!
And it's just... It's just insane to think about!
It's insane to think about!
And I'm really thankful too.
And they sent me like care packages and everything.
And it's just a really huge shout out to uh... to Neopets team.
Uh... TNT for...
for organizing all of it.
And that's what basically...
basically what tomorrow's stream is.
Um... So... The two announcements.
Neopets stream tomor... Neopets sponsored stream tomorrow!
And ACGHK!
Yeah!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
I'm super excited for it.
I can't...
Oh my gosh!
LilDoki would be so... would be like what the fuck.
Sorry I would not say what the fuck during the ACGHK thing.
But like LilDoki would be like what the fuck.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
It's such a... such a huge honor.
I'm so excited for you guys to see uh... the merch that will be sold there as well.
Um... Regarding if there's gonna be online sales for the merch, I'll ask my... I'll ask my management team.
Um... Because I actually don't know the answer to that.
But if there's... I think like I'll see... I'll ask if there's like uh... if there's like remaining stock.
If they can sell it online as well.
Um... I saw the key visual of it.
It looks really amazing.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Um...
But yes!
Those are the two announcements!
That's basically the two announcements of uh...
the day.
I'm really really... really happy.
And oh my god there's...
Ha ha ha!
That's why I'm saying everyday I'm just so busy.
I'm just so fucking busy everyday.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Thank you everybody.
Thank you all uh... for the support and everything.
I really really do appreciate it.
Um...
Sorry.
My mom came in and was like remember to say these things.
And I was like I already said it.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
So you're like...
Why is she muting it?
I was like... I was like... I already said it.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh my god.
Um...
Um... but thank you guys.
Um... thank you for being here.
For...
my journey.
To be able to have...
Like just to be able to experience all of that.
I never expected to you know be able to get to experience these things.
Anyway!
It's a long time coming.
But we're finally gonna have donation reading time.
Yay!
It's been... It's been 20 years!
But finally a Doki will read her donations!
I'm sorry.
There was so many things going on.
But it's finally here!
Ha ha ha!
I have time!
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay.
I need to do like... Let me make sure there's an outline though.
So there's an outline for us.
Wait.
What color can I... Can I not change the outline color?
Oh there I can.
Let's see.
What the fuck?
Why can't I change the outline color?
Um... Guys sorry.
It's been like a while.
Since I've had like...
Uh there we go.
Yeah!
Donation reading time!
Let's go!
Alright!
Wait did I hit 750k subscribers?
Oh my god!
We have 50k left till the special karaoke.
And I also have to finish the fucking climbing game too.
Cause I promised that for 700k.
Oh my god!
We literally hit exactly 750!
Thank you everybody!
For 750k!
Uh...
For the subscribers!
Oh my god!
We've like... We've...
Oh my god.
Thank you.
It's just crazy to think about.
But we're at 750k now.
Exactly.
Thank you everybody.
Uh...
For subscribing and supporting me.
It's just...
Um...
Next.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But will she read this?
Yes!
I have!
I've just read it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alan!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's a donation reading?
Cause I think it's been like months since we had this.
So I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
But we're back!
We're fucking back guys!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Mel!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... Weird!
I'm on work wifi so I'm experiencing the new intro at 240p.
Just as Toki intended.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... JL!
Oh no.
Being dragged into retail hell again.
Here we go again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god!
Um...
Uh...
Thank you for... uh...
Uh... Oh yeah.
I hope you guys like the new intro.
I'm thinking about like... for the... for future...
I would love to do like future intros with just different outfits.
I think that would be really fun.
Like every time we get a new outfit, we get a new intro.
We're...
I think that would be like... I feel like that would be like... uh... be a nice like little thing.
Um... every time.
So like... and then like when I'm using that particular outfit, I'll swap to that intro.
And...
So then you'll be like, oh she's gonna be using that new outfit today.
Uh...
So I think I might do that in the future.
Um... I saw somebody like, when will there be updates on the discord for the Minecraft server?
There are a few of us with technical difficulties and we don't know where to turn it.
Soon!
Um...
I was supposed to make it yesterday.
But then I fell asleep.
I'm sorry.
It will be made either today or tomorrow!
We're gonna be implementing the new chat update like either... I think tomorrow?
Oh my gosh!
Okay, speaking of the Minecraft update, uh...
the Minecraft server update.
They are making a coliseum for you guys to fight each other.
So let me show you guys a picture of it.
They actually sent me like an update progress of it.
Uh... where is it?
Where's the... Doki server?
Oh my god.
Here.
I'll show you guys.
They're making a coliseum right now.
Um...
So you guys can fight it out.
So like I said, we're getting like regular...
We're gonna be getting regular updates for this.
Look!
There's gonna be a coliseum.
Guys.
You guys are gonna be like... press a button and then you're gonna fight each other.
And you're gonna spawn in with like materials.
Like with... uh... with already like...
And then you gotta do teams too.
So there's gonna be like teams and stuff for the battles... battle coliseum.
Like this is just whoever wants to challenge each other.
And just like...
fight... like you know... brawl it out.
So this is gonna be like one of the first up...
like updates.
That and also the chatting system.
Uh... a better chatting system.
Um... so that you can chat with just your factions or like with particular groups that you started with.
Um...
Yeah!
And...
so like that's like... uh...
that's like one of the huge updates that we're gonna be doing.
The server will be up whenever...
if... whenever I finish my other work and I can make the server today.
Or tomorrow.
The server will be made...
will be made either today or tomorrow whenever I have time.
So... don't worry.
We'll get there.
There's a long to-do list.
I made a to-do list and we're very slowly getting there.
We're...
We're almost there.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doctor!
Mmm... yummy CPU.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... Aqua!
Thank you for- Okay, Aqua.
Um...
Aqua... we haven't done this in a long time but like...
Aqua, I'm not even gonna read your super chat but...
I would say thank you for the super chat but there's a reason why we're not gonna read your super chat.
There we go.
Uh...
Alright.
Alright, Aqua.
I hope you're...
I hope like...
I hope you know why I'm not reading it.
Um... Gamita, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you plan on going to EVA this year?
I cannot confirm or deny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
DreamAura, thank you for the super chat.
First time I've caught a stream live.
I just wanna say how much I enjoyed your appearance.
I do.
I mean hoping for a UK con appearance in the future.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not...
this year, I feel like.
I don't know if...
Um...
I don't know if there's any...
There's still few other conventions that haven't been announced yet.
But, um... for this year?
Uh...
But I'm not sure...
if UK...
I don't think UK is gonna be for this year.
Next year... Next year is definitely...
gonna be a lot more chill when it comes to convention appearance.
Um... because...
like I said...
Um...
I booked myself a lot for a lot of different conventions this year.
Um... because I wanted to, you know...
I never had the chance to...
to be able to visit so many different places around the world in terms of meeting my dragoons.
So that's why I went super...
like hardcore mode.
Um...
because like... I said yes to a lot.
I said yes...
uh... to a lot of places.
Because like I know there's a lot of places that never had a chance to meet me in the past.
And like, you know, I'm trying to catch up with Lost Time with all of you guys.
Um...
To be able to like...
uh... have this opportunity because...
I don't know if I'm gonna have this opportunity again in the future.
Uh... so that's why I was like...
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Uh...
So...
Um... I... for next year though, I'm definitely gonna...
I'm gonna try to pick places or conventions maybe that I haven't done before.
For next year.
Like that's gonna be my main priority.
Um...
To focus on more so on like places and conventions that I haven't done or like specific conventions that I haven't done before.
That doesn't mean I won't do like repeat conventions.
I might consider repeating some... a few conventions.
Um...
But my priority is definitely gonna be picking new places for next year.
Um... because you know I wanna be able to meet as many dragoons who's never had a chance to meet me before.
You know?
Like that's like my main goal.
To meet... uh...
To give dragoons an opportunity to meet me.
To like...
be able to see me and everything.
And... yeah!
That's how I wanna go on for next year as well.
Um...
Alright.
Where... where am I on my Super Chats list?
Oh my god.
It's been so long.
I almost forgot what I like to read... do Super Chat readings.
Uh...
Um...
Let's see.
Aura!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Remember to tip your barista.
They're doing their best.
I got paid today so here's my dookie tax.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
CB Miracle!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Today no game.
Just chatting.
Darkblade!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Now I'd win in the Dragoon Coliseum!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Drygo!
Uh...
Thank you for... for the Super Chat.
Reptik!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Long pause.
Let's see.
Uh...
UnfriedRice!
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Are you caramel or car-mel kind of pronounced its car-mel.
I pronounce it car-mel though right way.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, Thank you.
Brody!
We had money for college.
Yeah, we had money for college.
Good catch, good catch.
We're not getting that deposit back, guys.
I don't...
Guys, I don't think we're gonna get that deposit back, guys.
Oh my god, did you guys see the Junji Ito Sanrio collab?
Oh my god, I was like...
But...
That was like...
That was like one of the craziest crossovers I've ever seen.
Like, it just...
I don't know, did it make it that...
Okay, it makes a lot of sense, but also it didn't make a lot of sense.
It makes a lot of sense because Junji Ito is...
Loves cats.
Like, he is obsessed with cats.
He has like a comedy slice of life...
Slice of life manga.
That's just like dedicated to like living with his cats.
But then he has like the craziest like horror shit ever.
Yeah.
Okay, guys.
It's just...
Oh my god, it's like a pop-up store.
Wait, I'll show you guys the picture because I can.
I don't know.
I don't know how I feel about it.
Like, I love Junji Ito and I love Sanrio.
But like...
I don't know.
I don't feel about this.
It's definitely like a combo.
I like...
Wait, does Cinnamoroll not have eyes?
Oh my god.
Did they like...
What the fuck?
They...
Oh my god, they even...
Oh my god.
They made...
What?
He has no eyes.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is the merch.
He has no eyes.
Okay, look at the merch.
Can I even...
Can I even drag this?
No!
I need to snip it.
I can't drag it.
I can only snip it.
Give me a sec.
It's a web file.
No, not a web file.
Alright.
Guys, look at this.
Look at this Cinnamoroll.
Why does he have no pupils?
Why do the...
Why do the women have pupils?
Oh my god.
Where did the pupils go?
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Spooky Cinnamoroll.
That's so spooky.
It's like, it's literally a spooky Cinnamoroll.
Wait!
What the fuck?
I just, oh my god.
Wait a ju...
Wait, what the fuck?
I just noticed this.
Oh my god!
I really...
I just noticed that!
Yeah, they added the Two-Faced Lady.
What the f- They added the Two-Faced Lady!
Okayoni, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Just want to take the chance to thank you again for coming to Anime North Tokyo.
It was my first convention ever, so seeing you made it very special!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm glad I made it feel super special.
And honestly, I love meeting all my dragons during these convention appearances.
Like I said, I'm trying to include as many different places as possible.
Because I know for a lot of you guys- I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, South America.
I'm so sorry.
Spam your convention organizers to invite me!
But I'm trying my best to include as many places as possible so you guys can come and meet me.
But what the- I'm just so surprised!
I never expected Junji Ito to collab with Sanrio!
Of all- I don't know, it's such a- It's such a wild collab in general for me because it's like- It's like- It's such- It's just- I get like Hello Kitty, but still.
It's still like- It's a collab I never expected.
It's gonna- I don't know.
Junji Ito has a lot of really crazy fans.
Like, as in like- Junji- Like the fans are incredibly fanatic about Junji Ito.
But they don't- I guess like- I mean, I like Junji Ito and I like Sanrio.
But like, I would never expected them to do a collab together.
So it's- It's quite- It's quite- I was just really surprised.
I don't know how to explain it.
I was like, whoa.
Whoa.
Let's see.
Uh, ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Uh, Neffy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Dokie.
I'm enjoying your Minecraft server.
I wanted to ask if loading houses are allowed on our land.
Yeah.
Yeah, you guys can go wild with your builds.
Just as long as it's not like- You know, like you're making lag machines or anything.
So go wild.
Also, we added a new command in the Minecraft server.
If you do slash lobby, I think it takes you to the main lobby.
The main lobby area.
So you don't have to- I'm sorry for all the people that traveled 10,000 blocks to get there.
Uh...
But...
Now you don't?
Uh, Chi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't get small- odd in the meet and greet raffle for Annie Revel, but I'll definitely come to all your public panels there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, Chi.
There's more than just a panel and a meet and greet.
That's all I can say.
There might be a special guest.
I don't know if I'm allowed to say that, but like- Whoa.
I might be bringing a special guest with me.
Um...
Uh...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... You spoiled a lot.
I...
Really gonna do...
I'm the boss here!
I...
I own my own...
I guess myself?
Like...
What I'm gonna do?
I'm the boss!
Um...
Let's see...
Uh, where was that?
Where...
Uh, Chaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why did you write my name on that cup?
I didn't.
I didn't order yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
I'm the company!
Exactly.
I am the company.
Uh...
Boytan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Double...
Restretto...
Venti...
Half soy...
Nonfat...
Decaf...
Organic...
Chocolate brownie...
Ice vanilla...
Double shot... gingerbread frappuccino.
Extra hot with foam whipped.
You don't... is that real?
What's the craziest order that like somebody has given you?
Also Voitan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also Fun, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
What's like the... any baristas in my chat?
What's the craziest order that like a Karen gave you?
What is the craziest order that you had to do?
I'm actually curious.
Like are these real people?
Like there's no way.
Where's...
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See you in Caledonia.
I'm glad to know there will be more than me in Greece because I couldn't get an honor.
No!
Thank you for the super chat.
Alan, thank you.
Thank you.
Sorry, the raffle was limited.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
There's a lot.
Even like...
As I know like the...
The Hyatt booth was also like raffled as well.
Like the tickets were raffled but it was so funny seeing like some of the dragoons that were just looking at the side.
Because they fenced it off.
It was so funny.
Like they fenced off the...
The booth because they don't want to overcrowd the booth area because it could be like, you know, fire hazard.
So then... But then they had to fence it off during like the performances.
But I could see like the dragoons like huddled on the side like looking in.
They're like, I don't have a ticket but I'm gonna... I'm gonna watch it illegally.
I thought that was so funny.
I was staring at you guys like, I'm gonna watch it illegally.
It was really funny.
I could see you guys on the side.
Six straight expression shots?
Jesus Christ!
That is not healthy at all!
Let's see.
Absolute!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Asi knows good coffee.
Wait, what?
They kicked out a coffee shop?
An experience... Oh my god!
Australians!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
What else?
I'm gonna do three more super chats and then...
And then we're gonna call it here.
Because like I said, there's a lot to do.
There's a lot to do.
I have a very long to-do list.
But yesterday, I passed out early yesterday.
I've been having like an issue yesterday where I'll be like, I'm gonna take a nap.
And then like I... It was not a nap.
It's happened way too many times lately.
I'll be like, I'm so tired.
I'm gonna take a nap.
And then I wake up and it's like 6 in the morning.
And I'm like, oh no.
And I'm like, maybe I should get up.
And then I'll be like on my phone for two more hours.
And I'll be like, okay, now I should get up.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It was nice meeting you at the Dokimi panel.
I was able to get into the middle of the group photo.
It's a nice reward after my seven hour trip.
It's almost 1 a.m.
on my side.
So, F me for me and the rest of the EU dragoons, I guess.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'm so happy there's so many EU dragoons during the Dokimi panel.
I was so surprised because like, you know, you guys have to wake up so early or stay up really late for my streams.
So, I really, really, really appreciate it, guys.
I'm really happy that...
a lot of you guys showed up during Dokimi.
I hope I can have meet and greets too in the future for Europe conventions.
Oh my god, I'm super excited for...
It's gonna be a one-off for the Saturday stream for Digimon.
Because like, that game...
One of my very first PlayStation 1 games was the original Digimon World that my dad got me.
But it was in like Japanese.
So like, I had no idea how to play that game.
I told this story before.
But like...
Um...
I had no idea how to play...
What I was doing in that game.
But I have a lot of good memories of it.
Because like, I just really loved raising the little Digimon until they died.
I didn't even know how to save my game.
I didn't know how to save my Digimon World game.
Because it was all in Japanese.
And then...
So every time I boot up the game, I would just like restart from the beginning.
It's basically like Tamagotchi, basically.
Digimon World is basically like...
I don't care about...
I'm so sorry.
But I...
Personally, I don't like...
I don't really...
Um...
I don't really like...
I don't really care...
Not like, like...
But you know, my preference.
I don't like RPGs.
Like JRPGs in general.
So like...
But I like Digimon World.
Like I didn't understand what the fuck is going on.
I could not...
I could...
It's a long game.
Like Cyber Sleuth.
It's a very long...
Because I tried to play Cyber Sleuth.
Because like...
I was like, okay.
I need that itch.
I need to scratch Digimon World itch.
I need to...
Yeah, Digimon was made...
Was basically the...
Because Tamagotchi was so popular...
Um...
With like girls.
They made Digimon to...
Appeal to...
Like to appeal to boys.
Um...
So like...
Digimon was...
Digimon was practically like...
The boy version.
The male equivalent of like Tamagotchi.
Um...
To like...
Yeah.
And...
Um...
But yeah.
Basically like...
I've been always trying to scratch that Digimon World itch.
Because it's like one of my favorite games.
Uh...
Of all time.
Even though like I had zero understanding about what's going on.
Um...
But I just really enjoyed playing the game.
And...
I've tried to...
I've tried other Digimon games.
I'm sorry.
But like...
There's not a lot of good Digimon games.
I don't know.
I don't know if you ever watched that video from like...
What's her name?
Uh...
Jaden Animations.
And she was doing like this whole like...
I've been trying to figure out what's a good Digimon game.
And like...
Everyone will think differently of what they consider is a good Digimon game.
Digimon World was my good Digimon game.
Um...
And then...
I never played the newest version.
This is apparently like...
Um...
Like I don't...
It's not like a...
It's like a sequel to the original Digimon World.
And obviously it has like it's own thing too.
Um...
So like...
Uh...
It's gonna be a one off.
Um...
Because I don't think we're ever gonna beat that game.
I read it's very hard to beat.
So...
It's very hard to beat.
It's very grindy.
Because like the Digimon actually dies.
Um...
If you guys never played it before.
Uh...
So like you have like a little time frame to beat the game.
Like...
It's cause like when they die you go back from zero.
Basically.
So I'm really excited.
Digimon is like...
I don't know if you guys know this but like...
Uh...
It's...
Digimon is like...
Is...
Oh my gosh.
I love...
I love Digimon more than Pokemon.
I...
I'm gonna say it.
I personally love Digimon more than Pokemon.
But like in the West.
That is like a different story.
Because most of the Digimon content.
Does not release here.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
Do you know.
Do you know where most of the Digimon content is released in?
It's released in China.
Because like people in China.
And I love Digimon!
There's so many exclusives there.
And like, oh my god, the merch for it is so good too.
Like...
It's really... like there's a lot of exclusive merch made for Digimon.
And shows and games too.
There's exclusive games that just released there and everything.
And um...
NA, they just don't release Digimon stuff in NA!
There's just not big enough fanbase!
I'm just so sad!
Like, I wish the fanbase for Digimon was bigger!
It's just not fair!
It's not fair!
What's my favorite Digimon?
Okay, this is a joke.
Digimon, that's my favorite.
But like...
I love it because... I talked about it before.
I love...
I...
Okay, okay, wait, wait.
Um...
I...
His name is Betsumon.
And...
And he's based... he's an actual Digimon.
And the reason why I love Betsumon...
Because... okay, that's just like my joke love.
It's not my favorite, favorite Digimon.
But like... he's like my favorite design.
Because it's so dumb.
He's basically... he's basically like the cosplay Digimon.
Like he's literally the cosplay Digimon.
Because...
Anyway...
Um...
This is my favorite Digimon design of all time.
Because I... I just think it's... it's funny.
I just think it's really funny.
Um...
But... yeah.
My favorite Digimon is like...
Uh... Gatomon.
Terriormon.
Uh...
Uh... I don't like Patamon.
I'm sorry.
I... I... I...
I don't think...
I... like... I know everyone's like...
But Patamon is like basically like the Digimon Pikachu.
I...
Patamon's ugly.
I think Patamon's ugly.
Okay.
Um...
Anyway, I think...
Gabumon was one of my favorites too.
But then like...
Like I said...
Um...
Gabumon... Gabumon was ruined for me when I realized like...
Uh...
How dare you.
I am gonna say... I'll say it again.
I think Patamon is ugly.
I think...
It looks like a fucking naked mole rat.
Um...
With wings...
With wings on his head.
Um...
Anyway...
I...
I used to like Gabumon.
But then I've realized that like...
Uh...
He has...
He...
He's like basically like a lizard.
Wearing a skinned Digimon on top of him.
And then like...
There's like...
Oh, this is what Gabumon might look like with a...
Without it.
And I'm like...
Uh...
And...
And then like...
I stopped loving Gabumon.
I...
I can never love him again.
Um...
But for those who don't know...
I showed this on stream before but...
This is what Gabumon could look like without...
Without the...
Without his...
Like pelt on.
I'm just like...
Uh...
But...
I love him.
Ugh, brother!
Ugh!
Anyway, uh...
But yes, and I like... oh, I like the...
I like, uh...
I like all of...
I think peak design...
Gen 3.
Gen 3 Digimon, peak design.
Digimon Tamers, all of them...
except for the little, like...
Imp guy.
Uh, peak designs.
I'm sorry.
I don't know anybody that actually likes that guy.
Like...
Digimon Tamers, best designs overall.
But like, except for that fucking Imp guy, whoever... I forgot his name.
But like... Impmon!
People love Impmon.
I'm not one of them.
I think he's...
Like, he has a good... okay.
You can say he's a good character, or I'll say... he's a...
good character, but like, I hate his design.
Like, you can't... I don't care.
I don't care.
He might be the best...
maybe like one of the best character developed...
uh...
character developed Digimon in the show.
But like...
I just don't like his design.
I'm sorry.
Like...
I just don't like his design!
Uh... No name.
Super Chat, thank you.
Your tomato without your skin...
Yeah, but at least I look hot as a tomato.
Like...
At least I don't have a double chin as a tomato.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, no name.
Um...
It's just all head.
It's just all...
one head.
Um...
Let's see...
What else do I wanna say?
Um... But yeah.
I wish there was more Digimon content in...
Um... In the West.
But...
It's just not popular enough.
Because like, Pokemon has such a monopoly.
Pokemon has such a monopoly here...
That like...
It's so hard for Digimon to like...
do anything.
Which sucks!
It sucks!
Cause like...
I like the designs more.
I think Digimon has better designs!
I honestly think...
Digimon designs look...
a lot better than like...
Pokemon designs.
Like...
They have guns!
For arms!
That's so badass!
They have...
You'll never see a Pokemon with a gun!
Blade!
Thank you for the...
Magenta Supa!
Thank you!
Digimon Frontier is the one that has like...
Power Rangers mixed with...
Mixed with Digimon.
Is that the one that like... sucked?
Oh...
Sorry!
Blade!
Thank you for the Magenta Supa!
Um...
I personally...
I like...
Had no like... I didn't hate Digimon Frontier...
But like...
Digimon Frontier like...
Killed the franchise in the west apparently.
I...
Cause there's no actual Digimon!
It was just kids!
There was no actual Digimon!
It's like...
They are the Digimon!
I'm like... I don't fucking care about...
Them as the Digimon!
I want...
I want real Digimon!
I like...
I hate Digimon Frontier!
I was like... I didn't like... hate it!
I was just like... I was okay with it!
Obviously like...
They had to follow after Tamers!
And Tamers was like... the shit!
Like Tamers was like... basically like...
Hardcore... like...
Digimon.
While Pokemon was still like...
Ash is still 10!
And like...
Still... like... Ash is still 10!
And like... death isn't real!
In the Pokemon Universe!
Like people die in Tamers!
So like... haha!
And then Digimon Tamers...
Came out and they're like...
Death's real yo!
Digimon can die!
I was like...
What the fuck!
And I was a little... I was a little child!
I was just like... what the fuck!
You mean...
Death is real?
Hahaha!
Um... 73!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Congrats on your guest invitation for ACG, HK, and Sponsorship!
I'm excited for you earning these awesome...
Opportunities!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm really happy!
I'm so happy to...
Experience it with you guys too!
Um... let's see...
Uh... Pug!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Uh... Deputymon...
And... uh... Gundramon...
Are peak designs!
Changed my mind!
Pug!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh true!
He's like an actual gun!
Yeah!
For those who don't know, Deputymon is literally gun!
Hahaha!
Wait!
I forgot about that!
Hahaha!
Pokemon would never!
Okay!
For those who don't know...
What... what...
Deputymon!
Look!
I forgot about Deputymon!
Hahaha!
That makes him So cool!
He's so cool!
Hahaha!
Okay!
Um...
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
Anyway...
Where was I?
Uh... Hahaha!
I'm looking at Deputymon again!
Hahaha!
Okay!
Uh...
That's just...
That's peak Digimon right there!
What about Gundramon?
Was Gundramon the one with all guns?
Is that it?
Uh...
Let's see...
Oh my god!
Oh!
I remember!
I remember Gundramon!
Hahaha!
I remember!
I'm like... Nevermind!
I... Hahaha!
Guys, I remember what Gundramon looks like guys!
I remember that!
Okay, for those who don't know what Gundramon looks like, this is...
This is Gundramon.
This is... more guns.
Right here.
Hahaha!
This is...
This is... This is Gundramon.
Um...
Anyway... I wish...
I wish there was more Digimon.
I really do.
I... I love Digimon so much, but there's just not enough Digimon content.
Like...
There's nothing we can do.
Hahaha!
That's the American...
Oh my gosh!
I remember!
What stream was it?
Oh!
It was with Hiro!
Yeah!
It's so funny!
I think my favorite... I always love how like...
When I talk about Digimon...
To like other people...
Who just like... Who live like in Asia...
And all they know about Digi... Like you know...
The Digimon opening is like...
Butterfly?
I've never heard of... Like I told you guys...
I've never heard about Butterfly...
Until like... Recently...
Like you know... Like I think like...
Like um...
Uh... Maybe like...
Uh... Maybe like within like...
7 years?
That's when like I heard...
About Butterfly.
But like...
I grew up with...
Digimon... Digital Monsters...
Hahaha!
Digimon...
Digimon... Hahaha!
Like...
That's... Like I...
Butterfly is like the Japanese opening...
For Digimon...
And like people are like... Oh it's like the most famous...
Japanese opening...
Of all time... Like it's one of the...
That's one of the...
Most famous...
Um...
Anime openings... And I was like...
What?
I think... Oh yes!
The first time I've ever heard...
Butterfly... Was when they did the...
Movie reboot...
The movie reboot where Tai...
Were like adults slash teenagers...
Or some shit... And then so like...
They had a thing where like the Digimon Tamers...
Um... The Digimon Tamers...
The Digimon Tamers were singing...
The opening of Butterfly...
And that was the very first...
Time I heard Butterfly...
The... Cause I was like...
What the fuck?
Woah that's such a great...
Song!
I'll be like...
Wow!
I can't believe this movie...
Made this song!
It's so good!
Like... Hahaha!
Little did I know...
It came from the TV show...
Opening...
Hahaha!
Yeah sorry... DigiDestined...
Like... Hahaha!
I was like...
I'll be like... Woah!
I can't believe...
Like... I can't believe they made...
This song for this movie!
Hahaha!
And like...
I was like... Wow!
I can't believe DigiDestined...
I... Wow!
They got the...
DigiDestined to sing a song for...
This movie!
Woah!
Hahaha!
And that was the first...
Time I've ever heard...
Um... That's literally...
The first time I've ever...
Heard Butterfly...
Um... Because of the movie...
Um... Because I grew up with...
With the Digimon...
Digital Monsters...
The champions...
Like... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
That shit still slaps though... That shit slaps...
Man... Hahaha!
And then...
We tell them about... Yeah!
We had our own opening!
They'll be like... What the fuck?
Hahaha!
And I'll be like... What do you...
What do you mean you had your own English opening?
Is it as good as Butterfly?
And then I'll just be like...
Um... Yeah...
You can say that...
It was catchy!
It was a catchy...
Opening!
Like...
That's... That's something...
To be fair...
Like we always made up lyrics...
Like I miss the time when we made up...
Openings for like...
Anime... Because like...
Um...
You guys know how like... The Sailor Moon opening...
Is like super iconic...
The English one... Is like...
Uh... Fighting... What is it?
Fighting evil by moonlight...
Bum ba da da da...
Bum bum...
Oh my gosh... What was... I haven't heard the Sailor Moon opening...
In so long... Hahaha!
Um... But like...
The English opening... They made up words...
They made up words for it...
Uh... It wasn't even like...
Hahaha!
It had nothing to do with the original opening...
It's the same melody...
But it's a different...
Hahaha!
It's not...
It had nothing to do with the original...
Japanese opening...
It's the same melody...
Lyrics don't...
Lyrics had no connection...
With the original song...
Which I thought was really funny...
Hahaha!
I'm trying to remember...
Okay... The Moonlight...
Um...
Cause like the original lyrics...
Um... The original lyrics...
It was like... Okay let me see...
Translation... English...
Uh... Let me see...
The original lyrics...
Was a... Was a romantic song...
It was literally a song...
About like... Uh...
Romance and stuff...
It was a love song... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
It was literally...
It was literally a love song...
Um...
Uh...
But yeah... It was...
I thought it was like pretty funny...
Um...
This is a miracle of romance...
I'm reading the lyrics right now...
Uh...
Like look at this...
It's actually crazy...
Hahaha!
It's so...
It's so funny like rereading this...
Yeah and it's like the original...
Sailor Moon opening and we just made up...
We just made up English lyrics cause it sounded good...
Sailor Moon...
English lyrics opening...
English theme song...
Yeah it's just like...
Fighting evil by moonlight...
Winning love by daylight...
Never running from a real fight...
She is the one named Sailor Moon...
And then you fucking read this...
And it's like...
It's hard for me to say...
Although it's easy to say in my dreams...
My thought circuit is about to break down...
You know right now I want you with me...
That's like what it was supposed to be...
Like that's...
Hahaha!
That's the original lyrics...
And yeah...
I just thought it was fucking hilarious...
That's not an intro...
Hahaha!
Anyway...
That was a nice...
Sorry I forgot to do super chat reading part...
Because I started...
We had a long tangent...
Anyway I'm gonna call it here!
I'm calling it here everybody!
I always have a great time...
Hanging out with you guys...
As always everybody...
Be hydrated...
Posture check...
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing...
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!